Good Google [inaudible].
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is supported by Squarespace,
the all in one platform that makes it fast and easy to create your own
professional website.
Now,
that's what you're supposed to say.
That's their thing.
Uh,
when I say is,
it's the easiest way to make a website without learning dream weaver,
did he keep me learn dream or did they use that shit anymore without learning
html,
without actually trying to figure out the INS and outs of coding?
What you need to do is just go to Squarespace and make your own website with an
easy drag and drop interface.
It's super easy to do.
I could do it.
You could do it.
If you can do the normal functions of attaching a photograph to email and
clicking on links,
you can figure it out.
It's not hard and it's beautiful designs.
They have 24 seven support and they've also launched a logo creator.
So you can create your own clean and simple logo design for yourself in minutes.
You can set up an online store,
very easy to do,
easy to set up an online store,
easy to sell music.
If you're a musician,
you can sell digital downloads.
Squarespace has a whole ecommerce section dedicated to showing you how to figure
this all out.
They have a self help website that will,
that will better deliver the customer experience and for a free trial and 10%
off your first purchases,
go to squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe.
One of the other things that are really like about Squarespace is you don't have
to use your credit card to try it out.
You,
they'll let you sign up,
try it out,
build a website,
and then he'd go,
oh,
this is pretty bad ass.
Then you enter your credit card,
so I like that,
so you could test it.
Try it out.
squarespace.com enter the code word Joe,
get 10% off.
We're also brought to you by stamps.com which is another very easy and
convenient way to deal with things that you used to have to go somewhere for.
You used to have to go to the post office and get someone to weigh out your shit
and put different labels on each one of them.
With stamps.com you can print up you as postal from your own home computer.
Very easy to do.
You can print it.
You weigh it all out in a digital scale that they provide.
They give you a free digital scale,
$55 worth of free postage,
and you put this digital scale on it.
It tells you exactly what the price is and if the price changes,
like if the postage goes up,
no big deal.
stamps.com they have that programmed into it so you don't have to worry about it
at all.
Handed off to the post man.
And you're done so much less time,
so much less hassle,
no lines at the post office,
all done right through your desk.
And if you go to stamps.com and use the Promo Code J R e,
you'll get that no risk trial.
Hundred $10 bonus offer,
including the digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So go to stamps.com before you do anything,
click on that old school he microphone and the top of the homepage and type in j
r e that stamps.com j r e
and we're also brought to you by on it.
That's o.
N N.
I.
T.
Um,
if you don't know what od on it is,
if you've never heard of on it,
it's a human optimization website.
We essentially sell like the best strength and conditioning equipment we can
find as far as like kettle bells and battle ropes.
The best protein we can find.
We have hemp protein and we're going to talk to Dr Karl Hartley later about hemp
because it's one of the funniest things ever that helps illegal in this country
and it doesn't even get you high.
That's how stupid we are.
And we have a,
an awesome plant that tastes good,
has amino acids in it,
provides you with like a real complete pro protein,
very easy to digest and it's legal to have,
but you've got to get it from Canada.
We have to pay Canadian farmers to grow it and then bring it over here.
It's one of the dumbest things ever,
and it's just one more symptom of this goofy fucking country we live in,
ladies and gentlemen,
but it on it.
We sell,
uh,
things along those lines like the hemp forest.
We also have a,
the new warrior bar,
which is a,
uh,
a buffalo and cranberry bar done the way the native Americans did it.
It's really kind of bad ass.
Um,
it was by the same people that made the Tonka bar.
They've started making this new one,
the warrior bar.
It's really delicious.
No antibiotics,
no added hormones,
gluten free and no nitrates.
Um,
what we sell you would honor is all the best shit that we find the best
supplements,
the best foods,
the,
as far as like snack foods,
like hemp force bars,
the best strength and conditioning equipment.
We just try to sell you all the things that we use and all of the things that
you can use to optimize your physical condition,
your mental clarity,
and get your shit together.
Go to onnit.com o.
N,
N I t used the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
Dr. Carl Hart is here.
Choose the music and let's get cracking
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my name.
Hey Man,
thank you very much for being here.
I really,
really appreciate this.
Admired your work online of seeing a bunch of your videos and read some of the
interviews and uh,
I think it's,
it's incredibly important to have a guy like you out there.
It's incredibly,
it's incredibly important for a bunch of reasons.
One,
because it's important to spread the truth about drugs and to have someone who's
actually intelligent and a real professor who really understands what they're
talking about and to you look like us,
man.
I get normal.
You don't look like some weird stuffy dude.
You got dreadlocks.
You look cool as fuck.
Like I could hang with this guy guaranteed.
Any dude who has dry.
You can't be uptight.
Look at your hair.
It's impossible.
You know?
I think it's important.
It's very important.
I appreciate that.
Thank you for having me,
man.
The people have been telling me that I've got to come check you out.
So thank you.
Well,
I'm glad that connected us.
You know,
that's one of the coolest things about this whole Twitter social media thing is
that,
you know,
I get to find out about people like you and I get to be introduced by,
uh,
all these Twitter people want to get us together.
So it's pretty bad at it.
Right.
All right,
I'm happy to be here,
man.
[inaudible] again,
I say I'm happy that there's a guy like you out there because I've learned a lot
from what you're doing and I've learned a lot from some of the interviews that
you've had where,
you know,
you've had to kind of confront a lot of the ignorance that people have.
And it even kind of exposed a lot of my own ignorance and a,
I thought that was really fascinating.
And one of the things was you did a John Stossel interview where you were
talking about how many people use meth and coke and don't fucking ruin their
lives.
They,
they figured out how to keep it together.
Like,
yeah.
You know,
that's one of the biggest myths is that people think that,
uh,
individuals who use drugs like crack cocaine,
methamphetamine,
heroin,
they think that the majority of the people who use those drugs are addicted in
their life,
goes spiraling out of control.
They think that because it makes great TV drama,
for example.
And so we reinforce it in our sort of pop culture.
And also we can always think of somebody who screwed to life up as a result of
drugs.
But the people who don't screw their life up,
they don't talk about it.
They just go about paying taxes,
paying their bills,
handling their responsibilities.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Do you get pressured to not say that ever?
Because people say,
well,
hey,
you're going to encourage people.
And what if they go out and they do become addicted to drugs?
Like what are you giving them false hope?
Well,
you know,
that's,
uh,
I'm an educator first.
And so when we think about hiding information or not telling people the truth
because we were afraid that they can't handle the truth,
it's just illogical and I can't live my life like that.
I have children then I have to thank you for saying that.
Yeah,
no I don't.
I mean I have to teach my kids about sex.
I have to teach them about other potentially dangerous activities like driving
their automobile too fast.
Drugs is just one of those sort of activities and I'd be irresponsible if I
didn't tell them the best information that I know that's so important.
That's such an important thing to say and I've had that discussion with people
before where you know,
there would talk about any,
any sort of drug,
but I don't want to let people know I don't want to talk about it.
And I went because then I'll encourage them to do it.
Like a friend was telling me that about heroin.
He was saying,
you know,
heroin really is not that bad for you if you don't take too much.
It's really not that bad.
That sounds like sex.
I mean,
it sounds like a number of things.
You know,
it's like we all know this.
I mean it's just logical.
Anything that you overindulge and you can get in trouble.
Heroin is not different,
but there's a few that we have like these unfair assumptions about like crack
was the one from me.
I always heard,
dude,
you smoke crack once you're hooked.
Then I met a few people that have smoked crack and I'm like,
wait man,
you just smoked it once.
You know?
Like yeah,
so if anybody ever tells you anything about,
I did it once and I was hooked for life or a hook.
That's a license to stop listening because nothing in life you do once and your
hook.
That's just nothing.
Nothing.
What's the quickest to addict too?
Like is there,
there,
there are certainly physical addictions.
Like people do get alcoholism where they are.
It actually makes them sick if they stop like physical addiction.
Certainly that's a part of addiction,
but that's not the sort of main point of addiction addiction.
The main thing of addiction is like dis disruption of psychosocial functioning.
You don't pay your taxes,
you don't meet your obligations,
those kinds of things.
But you can get physically addicted to something like tobacco or those night
life threatening.
But it's irritating.
But the thing that we see that's more,
um,
that we think is excruciating pain.
His heroin addiction,
for example,
we think that someone is going through heroin withdrawal.
They are in such agonizing pain that day are on the verge of debt.
They're not,
if you've ever had the flu,
you've had heroin withdrawal and,
but the only one of the major drugs that we use today,
it's that connects really killed us from withdrawal.
It's alcohol.
And most of the people who use alcohol don't come near experience in alcohol
withdrawal.
To the extent that it would kill you.
You certainly can't die from heroin withdrawal.
Wow,
that's fascinating.
Um,
I've seen a guy going through heroin withdrawal.
I had a friend who was hooked on heroin and came out from New York to stay with
me in California in the 90s and I didn't know it at the time,
but his idea was that was how I was going to kick it.
So it came out to visit me and he was like,
look,
he had the flu for a week.
It just laid around in bed and then seven,
eight days later it was fine.
Yeah,
it's not fine,
but it's the flu basically,
you know?
So if you've had the flu,
you've had heroin withdrawal.
It's not pleasant.
And I don't recommend that someone go out and get the flu or heroin withdraw.
But the point is is that isn't that going to kill you?
And it's not as excruciating as is often portrayed in films.
And so those kinds of things,
they just do a horrible job of educating the public or miss,
educating the public.
And it wouldn't be bad if,
let's just say you do this sort of characteristic characterization and it didn't
have consequences.
The consequences is that we always have these repressive policies that follow
and then people pay the price.
Not so much from the drugs,
but from the repressive policies.
And that's a real concern that I have.
So the repressive policies lead to more prison sentences lead to more private
prisons lead to essentially people becoming,
it's like a form of slavery that's state sanctioned.
Certainly we have that.
And it also the major thing that it leads to this sort of dependency on that
economy,
like law enforcement,
they are also treatment agencies.
There are a number of people who depend on this sort of industry now or they
depend on this approach and it's hard to get out of there just approach because
right now in the country we're talking about liberalizing drug laws.
You can't liberalize drug laws unless you give police officers something else to
do.
You can't liberalize drug laws unless you give the treatment industry something
else to do.
And that's one of the things we haven't really talked about in this whole
conversation because those people are going to fight to keep their money and
they sort of are now,
I mean that is an issue now.
Prison guard unions lobby to keep certain drug laws in place.
Absolutely.
They are.
Uh,
they are intense.
So it seems to me like it needs to be,
there's a multipoint strategy
that has to be hit in order to make a transition between the prohibition that
we're experiencing right now.
And you know,
not having all these people completely fighting against it because of their
jobs.
Like there has to be some sort of a strategy for taking the resources that are
being applied right now to this unsuccessful drug war and doing something
healthy for communities.
Yeah.
You know,
that's one of the things,
I wrote my book recently,
high price and that's one of the things I tried to,
uh,
well I told the story,
it's a memoir and a science book.
So I told them memoir portion,
which is deeply personal and it's not something that I'm so comfortable doing,
but I have to do that in order to kind of contextualize the whole drug war and
what it all means,
what it all means.
And also,
um,
the science portion,
uh,
is there so people can understand what these days,
these drugs actually do and what they don't do.
And if you have that sort of contextualization and an understanding of the
science now,
you can probably make some reasonable logical decisions,
some choices about how we should deal with drugs in the country.
Now when you see something like,
or the country of Portugal,
which decriminalized drugs less than a decade ago,
right?
More than a decade ago,
almost one than our 2001.
And their results have been pretty extraordinary.
Yeah.
You know,
when you like Portugal,
let's just be clear.
So the audience understands what decriminalization means.
Decriminalization is not legalization.
Legalization is what we do with alcohol and tobacco.
Decriminalization would be like treating drug violations.
Like we treat,
um,
uh,
traffic violations.
You can't go to jail.
They'll get a felony charge,
but you may be subjected to a fine or so that's how they deal with drugs and
Portugal,
all drugs from heroin to marijuana to methamphetamine,
cocaine.
Now when you look at the major indicators,
for example,
drug use,
um,
they have less drug use than we do in this country.
When you look at drug related overdose deaths,
they have less than we do in this country.
When you have,
um,
the amount of money that they pump into their prison systems and so forth.
Of course they're pumping less than we do.
And so they're doing better than us on all of these major indicators and they
have no sort of plans to go another directions because they're happy with their
current approach.
And so that's one of the things I argue for in high price.
The book,
I argued that we should decriminalize all drugs in this country,
but in order to decriminalize drugs,
one of the things we have to also do is we have to increase the amount of
realistic drug education.
Not that just say no stuff that we've been peddling for a number of years,
but real drug education,
it's pretty ridiculous to think that you can educate anyone to the dangers or
lack of dangers in drugs in a 32nd commercial.
Right?
Yeah.
You know,
but that's not the goal.
That's the,
that's one of the things that people have to understand is that those folks who
came up with those 32nd spots that go was not drug education there,
drove their go was more prob propaganda.
And a fear based sort of,
um,
uh,
education if so,
if that's what we want to call it.
But that the goal was not really teaching
people about drugs and what drugs really do.
I had a joke in one of my old comedy specials about the Partnership for drug
free America because it was funded by alcohol and tobacco companies and I just
like alcohol and tobacco companies going after marijuana.
It's like hookers going after strippers.
I mean that's really what it's like with the idea of alcohol and tobacco
companies spending money to try to make marijuana illegal is it's unbelievably
stupid that tell you,
Bro,
if you studied this issue,
you will have a hell of a lot more material for your comedy routine,
not tell you it's because there are so many ironies that you wouldn't believe.
That's a brutal one though part.
And then the call was held partnership for a drug free America sponsored by
drugs.
Yeah,
but gang war of drugs.
The name of the Partnership for drug free America.
First of all,
there has never been a drug free society ever,
ever.
Nor will there ever be.
And nor do you want to live in a society that is drug free.
And so this whole notion of drug free,
it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Drugs encompass everything from coffee to alcohol to cigarettes.
It just goes on to Asai Berries.
No,
absolutely.
You know,
it's,
all of these things are drugs.
And so when people tried to make the distinction like heroin versus something
like caffeine,
the body doesn't distinguish something based on the fact that it's eleague ones
illegal in once,
not legal.
It has biological actions and consequences,
both of those things.
Why is it that this is something that's controversial to say?
Like what,
what you're saying right now on,
on this podcast,
you know,
a guy who's a distinguished academic saying these things,
it's very controversial.
Why is that?
If they are true and you are an educator and you have that philosophy,
which I admire greatly,
why is that rare?
Uh,
you know,
for one thing,
there are a few people in the country who actually know what drugs really do and
what they don't do.
So when you think about,
you know,
I have 24 years of experience,
have given drugs to animals and humans in the lab and carefully trying to
understanding the effect of drugs.
That's one reason.
I mean a number of people just simply don't know.
Another reason is that,
uh,
people,
scientists for example,
our conservative lot,
and they are reluctant to speak to the media in part because they don't want to
get their words twisted or they won't,
don't want to be appear to be wrong.
And so I,
I mean,
I respect that at some level.
Uh,
and so I think that that contributes on the one hand in and the other hand we've
had in this country for a number of years,
people who were in control of the narrative where people who had an addiction,
parents,
law enforcement,
none of those people are uniquely qualified to speak to this issue,
but they have dominated conversation.
Now how did you get involved in this?
You started,
you said 24 years ago doing drug research on animals.
How did,
what,
what was,
what led you to want to go down this road?
So I was in,
I tell this story in the book.
And so I was in the air force,
uh,
back in the 80s,
like you mentioned,
about crack cocaine.
So I was in the air force over in England,
and crack cocaine was a big deal in the United States as you point out.
And I grew up in the hood and Miami and Miami was a cocaine capital in the
United States.
And,
and so things that were happening in my community that were not good,
uh,
high unemployment crime,
all of these kinds of things,
I blame crack cocaine for that.
And so I thought that if I go to school and get a degree in order to study
drugs,
the effects of drugs on the brain,
I could solve the problems that face my community or the problems that I thought
were in the community,
particularly those related to drugs.
And so I began studying drugs as an undergraduate and then went on to graduate
school,
uh,
to study drugs on the brains of animals and to try to figure out the
neurobiological mechanisms that were responsible for addiction.
So you just got fascinated by this idea of fixing this,
this issue that you saw in your community and then you just fell into a rabbit
hole.
Yeah.
So when I started along my journey,
my path,
I actually got an education and you know,
so,
uh,
as James Baldwin said,
a,
you know,
the,
the paradox that education,
that's precisely it is as one begins to become educated and conscious,
one begins to question the society in which he's being educated.
And that's what happened with me.
And so along the way I discovered things like the majority of people who use
these drugs are not addicted.
That was one thing I discovered.
I discovered that many of the things that we set about crack about crack
cocaine,
we're just simply not true.
Like the cold crack baby myths.
And people said that when w that out generation beep should be prepared to have
a,
an army of kids who couldn't learn because of being exposed to crack cocaine,
that just simply wasn't true.
When all the data came out beginning in the mid 1990s,
we realized that that simply wasn't true.
Uh,
other things that I learned that just simply wasn't true.
uh,
things like,
one hit of crack cocaine,
you're addicted.
Not True.
That crack cocaine was different from powder cocaine.
All of these things I discovered along the way,
but they weren't,
they weren't true.
And not only that,
I discovered that this wasn't new.
I went back to the early 19 hundreds and saw the same sorta hysteria,
mainly race-based hysteria surrounding drugs occurred even then.
And so I thought,
what's,
what's going on?
And then that helped me to be more critical about my issue.
Is there a difference in the,
the effect of crack cocaine,
the physical effect
and,
and cocaine and heroin?
So let's,
let's think about crack cocaine,
heroin rather Robert
powder powder.
Yeah.
Let's think about crack cocaine and powder cocaine.
Let's just think about the chemical structure.
The only difference between crack cocaine and powder cocaine is that the powder
cocaine has this thing called the hydrochloride salt attached to it.
That salt prevents it from being smoked.
Now you can dissolve the powder cocaine and,
and water and then shoot into your arm.
And so you have the effects of cocaine,
uh,
onset of the effects within seconds.
The same is true with wood,
with crack cocaine.
The effects or onset of a sex effects are within seconds.
Now the biological activity of cocaine is at the base,
not that.
So that hydrochloride portion on the,
uh,
on the cocaine powder,
on powder cocaine has no biological activity.
Whereas,
so that means that crack and powder are the same drug.
They are exactly the same drug,
the same effect,
same drug.
Wow.
So it's indistinguishable to the user.
Indistinguishable.
Now why is it that they prepare it that way?
Like what's the benefit of preparing it?
It's just delivery.
Great question.
So one of the things that you,
you might recall Richard Pryor back in the days when he got,
he burnt and he burned himself.
What's would smoking.
So he was freebasing and so he was removing that hydrochloric portion of the
salt off of,
off of the cocaine base so he could actually smoke it.
Now he was using ether,
which is highly flammable with crack cocaine,
you don't,
now,
you no longer need the ether.
You just mix it up with baking soda and water and the cocaine and you mix it up
and you get rid of that salt.
So eat there is no longer need it and it's not as dangerous.
So that's one of the reasons that we have crack cocaine as a result of that.
And it also,
it made it so you could sell them in,
in unit doses to make the drug appear to be cheaper.
Because you also might recall in early 1980s,
1970s,
you had to buy cocaine powder in bulk and that made it more expensive.
Crack cocaine made it a lot more simple,
simple for people to buy it who didn't have the kind of,
uh,
expendable income that,
what's required before the mid 1980.
So essentially they just brought it down to bite size portions.
That's right.
Exactly.
Rather than selling this whole six pack or 12 pack,
now you can sell one item.
One can have one bottle.
I want to talk more about this,
but I should just clarify.
The Richard Pryor changed his story as he got older and actually said that he
tried to kill himself.
He lit himself on fire.
Apparently.
Um,
I'm a huge Richard Pryor fan and I know that that was originally what he had
said,
that he got burnt doing freebase but I think he changed the story later.
Um,
I actually worked with them a bunch of times right before he died was a real
honor.
He's a real special dude as far as a standup comedians go.
Yeah.
Which you,
but that,
that um,
uh,
style of,
like free base was a thing that we'd associated with people that were really,
really fucked up.
Yeah.
Like the guys doing coke.
Oh,
well,
you know,
he's probably gonna mess up his life.
He's freebasing.
Oh Shit.
He's gone,
man.
He's based and he's a bass head.
Yup.
Right.
Base head was the thing before crack heads.
Absolutely.
I described a couple of people in the book from my neighborhood who got into
freebase thing and exactly the same way you just talked about,
right?
Absolutely.
Um,
now everybody has this idea in their head that crime and that everything
escalated in the world changed when crack was introduced.
Is that a meth as well?
Yeah,
it's a myth that,
well,
let me clarify it because
on the one hand,
so when crack hit the market,
it was first sort of,
uh,
talked about December of 1984 and the La Times,
the first time we heard a crack,
but it didn't become a more widely known or available until maybe the mid 19.
My hit 1985 now once crack cocaine hit the markets,
what happened was that people were fighting over various new markets and
whenever there are new illicit markets,
yeah,
you're going to get some violent activity until the market settles down.
That happens with any illicit market and that's certainly happened with crack
cocaine.
Now,
one of the things that people,
there are a number of things that people attribute to try to crack in terms of
crime.
And all of the sort of downfall of certain communities,
unemployment.
They said that unemployment really rose as a result of crack cocaine being
around now 1982 the unemployment rate in this country was about 11% for white
folks and it was double that for black people.
That was before crack,
at least two,
three years before crack even hit the market.
Now doing the whole crack era,
unemployment has never been as high as 1982 that's number one.
People said things like,
uh,
people from my community,
crack cocaine was responsible for these mothers.
These grandmothers now raising new generations of kids because their daughters
were strung out on crack and so now they have to take care of these kids.
That simply wasn't true.
It's certainly happened in in my community,
but it happened before crack cocaine was ever on the market.
It's certainly happened in my family long before crack cocaine ever hit the
market.
When we look at other communities,
like particularly immigrant community,
if you look at the Jewish community,
when they came over to the eastern European Jews,
when they came over in the country,
the early 1,918 hundreds and so forth,
uh,
what you see is that you had a similar sort of phenomenon going on in those kind
of community.
And he said,
what's his name?
Urban,
how,
uh,
his great book land about fathers,
a home of our fathers.
He kind of described all of these pathological behaviors that happened in that
community.
Many of those same behaviors were attributed to crack cocaine and black people
later,
but it's not it,
they were there long before crack cocaine was dare,
but crack cocaine became the scapegoat.
That's a fascinating scapegoat because I bought into it hook,
line and sinker.
I really thought that there was a difference between the 1980s in the 1990s as
far as like when crack was introduced,
boom,
it took off.
It was sort of something that was just always discussed as like common facts.
Yeah,
no,
I bought into it too.
And that's what drove me to,
to pursue my education in a way I did.
But as a result of pursuing that education,
I discovered that it was not true.
So
are these cultural myths the result of a politician like political campaigns,
we're trying to clean up the streets and they attributed to certain issues or is
it,
is it something more widespread?
Is it the media just we're running with a narrative of what is it,
how'd it get started?
Well,
there were multiple sort of of factors and players involved.
So when we think about the politicians,
for example,
politicians,
if crack cocaine is the problem,
nevermind the fact that unemployment rates was out of control before crack
cocaine hit the mark,
hit the market,
unemployment was out of control.
A number of things were already uh,
problematic.
Now you have crack cocaine.
If you blame crack cocaine,
it's really easy to simply say,
we'll put more law enforcement,
we'll hire more.
Cops,
will put more efforts in controlling this drugs.
A lot easier to say,
we'll lock people up for selling these drugs for using these drugs.
In the process of what you do is you create jobs for a select group of people
and then you don't have to deal with the real issues,
the real issues of unemployment,
of deprivation.
All of these things you don't have to deal with.
They're far more complicated.
And so politicians are happy to buy in.
Now,
one of the things about crack cocaine is that when we think about the law that
punishes or punish crack cocaine a hundred times more harshly than powder
cocaine,
and the vast majority of people who got punished under these laws were black.
80,
85% of the people,
even though they don't make up the majority of the users.
So people will say things like,
well,
were those laws racist?
And the laws themselves weren't racist because the black congressional black
caucus,
17 of the 21 members voted to,
uh,
for these laws,
for these laws that punish crack cocaine a hundred times more harshly.
But the point is,
is that everyone bought into it,
parents bought into it because the parents did it for the parents.
What this meant is that you don't actually have to educate your kids about this.
You just say that they're bad and stay away from it.
No education required.
Um,
even scientists and treatment providers,
they all bought into it because you got a problem.
We're gonna solve your problem.
So we are needed and we are valued all.
So you had all of these sort of constituencies from society benefiting from the
vilification or an escape goating of crack cocaine.
All of those things think came together nicely and then we think about the
wrappers.
They all came into the game too because it's like,
I'm conscious,
I'm going to say that this is a problem in my community and I care about my
community and this is the way that I can show it.
So everybody had a stake in this sort of thing.
Wow.
That is absolutely fascinating.
You know,
one of the things that I've,
I've talked to quite a few people about when it comes to issues like real
complex issues like drug addiction and violence and poverty is that once you
feed it with any organism,
whether it's that organism is law enforcement or that organism is education,
whichever one you feed is the one that's going to grow.
And once you feed the law enforcement one and you look at this really complex
situation,
I think law enforcement is important,
but I think education is probably more important to avoid future law
enforcement.
Like the more I think the more education we have,
the the,
the more nuanced our ability to raise children is the more we understand that
we're all in this together,
the less you're going to need law enforcement.
But when law enforcement becomes this machine that lobbies against the
legalization of certain drugs,
which when you start looking at the data,
there's only one reason to do that.
And the only reason is that you're trying to stay alive.
You're trying to grow,
you're an organism,
you're trying,
you're trying to eat the sugar that's trying to keep going.
So you're creating more jobs by putting people in jail.
It's essentially,
no one wants to look at it like this,
but it's a form of slavery.
Uh,
I think we,
uh,
in the house I live in the film,
Eugene Gr direct these films.
I think that's the kind of analogy he was trying to draw in that film.
Absolutely.
So I think we get it.
I think a number of people get that.
That's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
It's exactly what it is and it doesn't seem like anybody's willing to address
it.
No one,
no one's willing to change it.
There's that very famous speech where Eisenhower,
it gets out of office and as he's leaving he addresses the nation.
He warns of the dangers of the military industrial complex.
And it's a weird speech because this is a sitting president and he's leaving and
he's letting people know,
like there's a machine out here that's growing and I'm letting I can clue you
into this.
Like be aware of this thing.
This,
the same with law enforcement.
It's the same with private prisons.
It's a,
they become organisms.
They'd become individual things that are filled with people that are all working
for the greater good of the individual of the,
of the Great Corporation.
Absolutely.
And people need to understand the conflict of interest that these folks have.
And oftentimes when we have these type types of discussions,
one or to sort of impulses of the media or,
or uh,
folks who have these discussions that they want to invite law enforcement
personnel.
It's like what expertise do they have to talk about drugs really run
none.
Well you remember Ronald Reagan when he was on TV.
Mara Mana may very well be one of the most dangerous drugs we've ever discovered
or that or whatever the exact yeah,
no,
no.
I,
I know,
you know,
I try to forget Ronald Reagan but I,
I hear you,
I had a conversation today about an actors with a friend and we were talking
about actors being in politics.
Like how crazy it is that you let someone who's a professional liar try to tell
people the truth.
I mean that's what an actor is a really good at bullshitting.
Like they pretend they're really sad cause someone they know just died.
Nobody fucking dive as cameras all around you.
There's lights on you,
you wear makeup,
but you're so good at bullshitting that I'm willing to pay money to see you.
Bullshit.
I mean,
let's think about what we consider news in the country.
And we think about the people who are delivering news.
They are the same.
They're worse.
They're too stupid to be actors,
right?
Most of them are,
you know,
and here's Bob with the weather.
Wow.
What a day,
what a day,
what a day.
The wind's coming in from the northeast and I do these radio tours and I'm sure
you do them as well when you,
uh,
you promote your books,
but you will hear the same voice over and over and over again.
It's like somehow none of these guys have plugged into what they think is a
radio guy and they're being,
they're playing the role of a radio guy and it's very strange.
Yeah.
There's a lot of strays things that has happened on this book tour is though.
So that's the people that we have disseminating information.
And in some cases,
uh,
running the government,
you know,
the Arnold sports and everything was so crazy.
You know,
we're running around telling everybody the fucking terminator is the governor of
the country.
That's ridiculous,
you know.
Yeah.
There's so much to say about the honor sweat sneaker as it relates to drugs too.
When we think particularly we think about performance enhancing drugs and no
discounts of thing.
You know,
we know about his shoes and then you think about the PA cracy of it all.
And that's the thing that's just disturbing if people just call it like it is
and say what it is,
you actually help people understand what these things do and what they don't do.
And then you don't have that.
People have all of this cognitive dissonance about,
uh,
it's like,
how can I get to that level?
How can I do this level?
Um,
uh,
when you,
when you know that those folks,
um,
uh,
did performance enhancing drugs,
so now they're saying that you shouldn't do performance enhancing drugs.
Yeah,
that's an interesting situation.
Um,
I,
I think there's a real issue with that in sports and there's a bunch of
different groups that are trying to clean it up.
And recently the UFC has made a big steps to try to limit the amount of
performance enhancing drugs.
But unless you're watching gars all day every day,
it's really hard to tell without testing them.
Well,
you know,
I don't know how I feel about the performance enhancing drugs thinking.
The thing that I like to know first of all is that we get better information on
it.
You know,
and I don't want to have this sort of just say no attitude towards this stuff
without really good information.
And I don't know if we're there yet.
I agree with you 100%.
I think the issue that people will have though is the,
the term natural,
you know,
natural is an interesting term because is it still natural if you're taking
multivitamins,
but what if you got creatines it's still natural.
If you drink coffee,
coffee's a drug you're kind of drug using.
Is it still natural if you use,
you know,
certain types of water that's treated certain ways to make your body process
oxygen better?
I mean whatever new thing that comes out is that still natural and it gets,
it gets real weird.
It's like she should be,
should people not be allowed to take any supplements so they just only have food
like this is what you give them.
Just plants and animal protein and water and then we monitor what your diet is
and then we let you fight.
Yeah.
You know there are,
there are a number of issues going on because I mean the whole notion of like
natural,
I think people need to grow up.
I don't even know what that means.
Natural.
That's not my concern.
My concern is that if you have performance enhancing drugs and then people are
giving,
given a drug in order to so they can continue to perform even though they are
hurt.
That's my concern that they,
that we run further a risk of having people being injured.
But in terms of training and that sort of thing,
I don't have so much an issue with that whole issue of,
of using performance enhancing drugs.
As long as we're doing it in a safe manner in which people understand what's
happening.
I think the,
uh,
the question is fairness.
That's the question.
You know,
fairness Americans are,
um,
they,
they annoy me with fairness.
I mean fairness really come on
worried that someone is going to cheat and they're going to win when they're
taking an illegal drug.
That's the,
I mean,
it's pretty simple.
That's the fairness.
That's the fairness argument.
So like when we think about,
uh,
our ability in this country to train better than some of our opponents in the
Olympics because we are a wealthier country.
Is that fair?
No,
definitely not.
Yeah.
So I mean,
just hold it and then we think about wealthy or people who,
who his kids can have,
uh,
access to,
prep tests before taking the sat before taking the m cat or some other exam,
whereas a less wealthy people can't afford those tests.
Is that fair?
Absolutely.
Just so issue of fairness is
come on right when it comes to combat sports and athletics though obviously I
have a vested interest in um,
in this idea and this debate,
but I think there is an issue of two guys have very similar,
almost identical economic situations,
uh,
identical training environments,
identical amount of experience in martial arts.
And one guy's taking a drug and the other guy isn't,
that guy has an unfair advantage.
Sure.
Certainly can be.
But you know the thing and that's fine.
Whatever the rules are now we must adhere to them.
All I'm saying is that I think that we need to make sure that we studied the
issue really well so that if one person has access to anything to add
and also should have access,
but right now the rules are that you can't,
that's fine.
Right.
So I totally understand.
So what you're saying is you think that the rules should be based on scientific
evidence of efficacy and of health benefits and risks and all that and have it
laid out and absolutely not.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
it really is.
It is kind of a weird thing.
Like you can sell test.
Like on it we sell a t plus enhancer it and it enhances your body's ability to
produce testosterone.
But it's legal.
I mean there is a bunch of stuff.
The like creatine,
creatine is legal.
You can,
they can't stop.
You've taken creating,
there's a bunch of stuff that,
you know,
it caffeine,
they'll let you take a certain amount,
but if you get above like 200 milligrams in your system,
they go,
oh no,
you don't like too much.
It's real weird.
Natural is a weird
word.
Yeah,
no,
right.
I know.
You know,
it's a difficult one for me.
I don't know the performance enhancing whirl,
uh,
as well as I'd like to.
But you know,
maybe that's an issue for another book.
Well,
you know,
this,
the term natural,
I got a,
a conversation with a friend of mine.
We were talking about pollution and all these different things that people do
and,
and we were saying,
what's really kind of weird is we always think of things that humans make as
unnatural,
but they're all made out of stuff on earth.
It's not like we're taking shit from another dimension and creating artificial
things.
Yeah.
Just like in the marijuana smokers,
they say,
well we is natural,
so does all drugs are natural.
You know,
it's like heroin comes from the opium poppy,
methamphetamine from a federal base plant,
you know,
cocaine from the coca plant as well.
So it's like all of these things are natural,
if that's what your definition of natural,
even this synthetic versions are created by earth grown components.
Absolutely.
Just synthetic versions might be better.
I mean like aspirin,
uh,
comes from the willow bark,
I believe it's like,
but we have made it since synthetic,
so we can harness dude the components that we need.
Uh,
so that's,
that's a good thing.
And that's a drug.
Yes.
Yeah.
So a drug free America would mean no Asprin,
no aspirin.
That's right.
It is pretty silly.
No d no coca cola either.
Yup.
Yeah.
That's a drug.
That's right.
We're filled with it.
Our culture is filled with it.
And that's such a great point that you made earlier.
Every single culture.
Absolutely.
So like kids who are trying to learn how to think critically when people present
them with things like drug free,
they should really question that sort of thing.
Um,
uh,
that they should be taught that this is part of critical thinking,
drug free societies just doesn't exist.
So please don't feed me propaganda.
So that really does exacerbate our issue,
right?
Because uh,
it,
with all that ignorance out there,
it makes it very difficult to have a real debate about it because people come in
to everything with preconceived notions.
Like,
I don't,
I don't know very much at all about chess.
I don't know who's the best,
I don't know what the strategies are.
I kind of know how the things move that makes two of us,
you know what I'm saying?
But if I came into chess going,
oh,
no,
you guys don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Like the way to do chest,
you gotta just move faster than the other guy.
I had all this crazy,
oh,
I'm fucking been watching on TV and you're a chess master.
You'd be like,
pitch,
what are you say?
And that is not how you play chess.
The fuck you talking about crack babies man,
the crack economy,
you telling me crack crack didn't ruin our economy.
Broke shut the fuck up.
It's like people already have this in their head like they're already coming to
the table with a bunch of bullshit.
I couldn't have said it any better man.
It's gotta be really frustrating when you go to cocktail parties and if I had a
cocktail party,
I invite you to look cool,
cool guy.
If you go to cocktail parties and people say,
well car,
what'd he do?
And he'd go out,
you know,
I'm a
shoe salesman,
man.
That's a good way to get out of it.
I used to tell Chickson I worked for my father's insurance company because
working for an insurance company is so unglamorous,
but working for your father's insurance company means you're such a bitch,
you can't even get your own job and insurance company.
He just,
some Ne'er do well that lives in his parents' basement and they would be so mean
to me.
It was so crazy.
This is what I was on television.
They be like,
Yo,
you got to inherit the company.
I should probably be push up.
Nope.
And there was none of that going on.
I wasn't flashy enough.
I didn't have enough shit.
If I was like pulling up in a Ferrari and I said that maybe then they'd be like,
hmm.
I was driving up Volkswagon Corrado at the time.
I just,
it was shocking how mean people could be because of that we have,
uh,
you know,
certain things that we accept and certain things we don't accept.
And when it comes to,
you know,
things that people talk about at cocktail parties and what have you.
And if someone comes along and says,
heroin's not that addictive cocaine doesn't ruin a lot.
A lot of people take on a regular basis,
you're going to encounter a bunch a know it all right,
don't you?
You must.
Of course.
Do you know?
Um,
so I mean,
uh,
so that means that I have to make sure that I don't engage in conversations with
people who don't play by the rules of evidence.
And so if I engage,
if I engage in those kinds of conversation,
I'm too old for that man.
And so I try to limit my exposure to people who are,
who are um,
uh,
mainly faith base in there,
sort of a belief system.
It
becomes a real problem when they're really smart about something else.
Like I had a conversation with Michio Kaku once and uh,
we were talking about Panspermia,
it was a on the opiate Anthony show,
we're talking about the concept of the building blocks of life coming in from
asteroids and that that might be where a lot of things came from.
And,
uh,
one of the things that we were discussing was,
was psychedelic mushrooms.
Cause Terence Mckenna had this theory about psychedelic mushrooms coming spores
coming from another planet.
It's very possible that asteroid impacts that carried all the other building
blocks for life also carried psychedelic spores,
which is why they're so uniquely different from any other plants on earth.
And I was asking him if he ever did mushrooms,
my sneaky way of asking Michio Kaku if he did mushrooms,
but he started going off about it given you brain damage and becoming addictive.
And I'm like,
what are the fuck you talking about?
It's so unfortunate like that.
He was talking about it ruining your mind.
Like I'm trying to improve my mind.
I'm like,
oh,
come sir,
please.
You're,
you're,
you're like a blind man describing in kaleidoscope.
And it unfortunately,
it makes you question all the things that that guy's an expert in because if you
know something to be untrue,
and here's this brilliant guy who's telling you about the universe itself and
the,
the building blocks of matter and he's so smart and he's so definitive with his,
his,
his definitions and descriptions of these things.
But then he tells you something that you absolutely know to be incorrect and you
go,
well,
come on.
Where's this is your fucking awesome?
Why are you saying this?
Like you're the one who's telling me about the cosmos.
You're telling me about all these other cool things that I know are amazing and
scientifically provable.
But now you're saying some dumb shit as well and which you man,
I mean,
that's one of the things that we all try to guard against because,
uh,
we all have a limited sort of knowledge base.
We all do.
I mean,
we can only be experts in so many areas.
it's just requires so much work to be an expert in anything.
And so we have to have the humility to say,
you know,
I don't know that as well,
but I'm willing to keep an open mind and learn.
Um,
so you're right.
Uh,
I hope that I don't overreach like that on any subject matter because I know
drugs very well.
Other things I know less well,
that's such an important thing and a lot of really smart people don't ever want
to admit that.
You know,
there's a lot of really smart people that are really smart about one thing,
so that you question him about things that they're not really smart about,
where they don't really have as much information about the bullshit.
Sometimes that's fucking dangerous.
Um,
which you man,
and I'm so glad that you,
you expose that kind of thing and you highlight the concern related to that.
But you know,
that's,
uh,
we have to be able to say,
I don't know.
Yeah,
it's,
it's an important factor.
Like in distributing information,
we have to know that these sources that we reach,
whether it's you or any other academic is a hundred percent honest and there's
no ego or fuckery involved.
And when these guys show a little bit of ego where they don't want to show
humility about their ignorance,
they ruined the whole thing.
The whole discussion gets,
it's,
it's very difficult to take them as seriously.
Absolutely.
And it waters down all the things that they say that you know are true as well.
It's like,
yeah.
You know,
on the one hand it's like we should be allowed the latitude to be,
to have been wrong,
but as a result,
we should also be able to say,
Oh,
you know,
I was wrong and I got this new information that made me see the light.
Um,
and so,
so it's a two way street.
You know,
it's like people are gonna make mistakes and we want them to be able to make the
mistakes because in the process of trying to understand something,
they might discover something really fascinating,
a good,
um,
and so they should be able to make a mistake,
but they have to also be able to say,
I screwed up.
Yeah.
It's really unique isn't it?
When people were running for president,
we don't want none of that.
We want no flip flop in.
If you're a flip flopper we don't want to think that anybody learn from their
mistakes and change their opinion or had some new information come in and they
reconsidered their ideas.
Eh,
one of the people who say that disk I flip flopped or this and that,
they don't speak for me and I hope they don't speak for the rest of the country,
although they may have the microphone,
but I hope people see through that nonsense.
They do.
But there are,
I think what they're trying to get at for the most part.
I mean,
I think we're,
we're,
we're certainly right when it comes to like you can learn,
you can change your opinion.
I certainly they've in my life and even
recently changed my opinions on things,
but I think they're just concerned which bullshit politicians that are just did
just completely play in the breeze.
That's where's it going?
I'm pro abortion.
Uh,
none.
None,
None.
No,
no,
that's right.
So you have that issue where people are,
like you said,
they are,
uh,
trying to make sure they have all the bases covered and they say one message to
one group and a completely different message to another group.
I know I get that.
But then there are politicians to who actually learned new information to change
their mind and then they get caught the flip flopper and that's bad.
Now,
when did you first,
when did you do your first research,
your first,
uh,
like research on drug effects?
I think the first study I published was in 1992.
And what was the climate like then in comparison to climate in 2014?
Cause we were talking about pre internet.
Yeah.
Damn,
that's pretty internet.
Al Gore hadn't,
he didn't just go up to discovered it.
And that night I ate to Al Gore,
probably already had it,
probably only had a cell phone with an arm.
Um,
I think,
well I got on in 94 and I think it's generally considered like 93 was when I say
pre Internet.
Like I think it all started around that area on the attitudes hadn't really
changed.
Nah,
I mean the attitudes,
the attitudes around drugs,
they haven't really,
I mean,
only until the past year or two have they really started to change.
People here are two people of like starting to open their mind to these issues.
Like maybe we'd been hoodwinked,
maybe we've been bamboozled,
but for a long time.
I mean we think about from Reagan to Bush one to Clinton to Bush to,
uh,
and even Obama at the beginning of his first term,
um,
attitudes about drugs,
they hadn't changed that much.
I mean,
the bottom line was that drugs were bad.
And as a politician,
what you say is that you're going to be tough on drug drug users and people who
sell drugs.
And that's,
that was popular until recently.
Now people were starting to say,
wait,
wait a second.
Maybe we have,
maybe we've been doing this wrong.
And,
but that's a recent phenomenon.
Do you,
what do you attribute the terrain changing of that tied to,
is it just the overwhelming information?
I think
there,
there are a few things.
I,
I think,
um,
Michelle Alexander wrote an important book called the new Jim Crow to help
people to understand the fact that we now have 2.3 million people in our prisons
and largely because of the war on drugs,
you know,
so it's like we have 5% of the world's population,
25% of the world's prison population.
And then we start looking at looking at the ratio,
sort of discrimination in terms of who's in prison.
Black men make up 5% of the population or 6% of the population,
35% of the prison population.
And just started to look at all of these numbers.
I think Americans are like,
well we are fair,
we are fair people in general.
And so I think they are disturbed by that.
I think helped.
And I think
the fact that my book,
uh,
I'm a scientist,
I've been doing this for some years.
Um,
I am on a number of boards,
respect at scientific boards.
I have played the game mainstream game and then I'm saying I've done the studies
and I'm telling you,
you've been misled.
So that has helped.
My book has helped.
And I think that,
so I think the economy,
the fact that um,
the,
uh,
we don't have the kind of money that we had,
we once had,
particularly in the mid,
late 1990s where we could build prisons and we could put all this money in law
enforcement.
I think all of those things have helped people to understand that maybe we're
doing something wrong.
And now with Colorado,
one of the things,
Colorado and Washington,
those two states have legalized marijuana.
And one of the things that's being really talked about is the amount of tax
revenues that the marijuana in Colorado is going to generate in this country.
Ultimately,
money remains king.
And so that has opened people's mind.
You know,
I like the think that empirical evidence helps to really shaped the way people
think.
But money is really king.
And I think that all of these kinds of things,
the economy,
Colorado,
some information,
the fact that we don't want to be,
you know,
moral people,
uh,
all of those kinds of things are coming together to help people to rethink to
what we're doing with drugs.
And if you looked at our culture,
if you will,
there are civilizations scientifically and saw those statistics,
those unbalanced statistics though at the very least you would have to say,
well,
there's an incompetency in engineering their culture.
If it's not racist,
if it's not,
if it's,
if they're not victimizing certain population of a certain percentage of the
population that can't defend itself as effectively and,
and taking advantage of them.
At the very least,
it's a very poor engineering of the civilization.
I agree,
man.
You know,
the thing is,
is that this is one of the things that one of the things I did,
I actually believed many of the Americans,
so to mythology that we were a fair people that you know,
equal rights for everyone.
And so I think a lot of us believe that.
And so I think as a result of us believing that sort of mythology and then
actually looking at the data,
I think people are disturbed.
I think that people are understanding that uh,
we are just about 50 years removed from the march on Washington and the famous
Martin Luther King speech,
I have a dream and that sort of thing.
50 years removed from that now.
And then we were all upset about the social injustice that happened during that
era.
Now I think people are understanding that we have our own social injustice
happening right before our eyes.
And,
and so the question becomes,
well,
where will history say you were on the issue?
And I think people are getting it.
I think I,
but I,
many people would just simply ignorant to it.
But I think the message is getting out now.
So it was just this combination of factors that are overwhelming.
The Internet providing all this information,
Colorado and Washington state providing alternatives to the economic situation.
All of the above,
all of them.
It is an issue.
It's one of the big issues when it comes to the difference between a democratic
leader in the Republican leader is the way they treat some sort of social
issues.
And that's a big one that the,
the way that the Obama administration is sort of sad that they were going to
treat marijuana and then the way they did treat it,
which is very different.
It was very Bush like it was,
it wasn't much different.
I mean error,
they've started recently saying that they wouldn't go after these states,
but there was a lot of people that went to jail.
A lot of people did time.
A lot of people are still involved in the court system.
I know people personally that have been busted and they were doing everything
according to state law fact.
So what,
what's that about?
That's a good one,
man.
Um,
you know,
I think about when Bill Clinton was elected in 1992 and I remember the
excitement that the country had because we thought that war on drugs and all
these things,
we're going to reverse them.
Turns out Bill Clinton under his administration,
more people were arrested,
any other administration for these sorts of violations and um,
at,
at until that time.
Uh,
and so I think a similar thing kind of happened under the Obama Administration.
It's hard for the democratic sort of leadership or the Democratic candidate or
president to,
uh,
go in a different direction for fear of being considered soft on drugs on crime.
Now I will say this,
this administration,
um,
uh,
as of late is the only administration that said that they were going to change
the way that the justice system,
for example,
uh,
in forced mandatory minimum drug laws,
they said they wouldn't be enforcing those laws anymore.
They sat,
that sort of thing.
This administration said that they will leave Colorado and Washington alone,
those states that have legalized marijuana because under federal law,
marijuana remains illegal.
So technically the federal government can come in and stop that.
But they have said they were going to allow it to happen and they said it's an
important sort of experiment.
And so on the one hand,
I'm certainly,
I,
I certainly wished they would do more the current administration.
But when we look at what previous administrations have done,
they have done more than any other administration
when it comes to drugs,
when it comes to drugs.
So there have been some horrible things like the busting of these medical
marijuana dispensaries.
But is that just a part of what we were talking about earlier that just the
machine needs to be fed and they,
it's way easier to do that then the knock on some trailer that's got smoke
coming out of it in the middle of the desert and some dude comes out when a
machine gun and you know,
you go into one of those medical marijuana,
you got a nice clean bust.
Yeah,
bring in a lot of cash.
And if people don't know the racket,
it's,
it's kind of hilarious.
Here's what they do.
They go,
they,
they arrest you.
They come in,
Jack booted with fucking bulletproof vests on and machine guns.
They hold people down,
they step on your neck when you're on the ground is videos of all this.
And I'm making this up.
They take all the weed and they take all the money and then they say that
they'll be in touch with you.
They say that they'll review your case.
That charges will be pending.
They decide when they're going to press charges,
when they're going to put your thing into a system.
So then these people have to decide whether or not they go back to work.
Yeah.
Do they decide whether or not they go back to there?
No one's been charged with anything yet.
You got arrested,
they took all your shit and then they let you go.
And so you're sitting there terrified and broke trying to figure out is this
worth doing more of?
And the people that work there often quit.
You've got to find new employees.
College kids don't like getting boots put to their face and you know,
got in their back for week.
Right.
And so they,
this money just evaporates and it's been millions of dollars worth of money.
It just sorta goes away.
No,
you can't get a hit.
You can't get it back.
It's not yours.
The weed,
it's ours now.
It just goes away.
No,
I mean,
these kinds of things needed to be,
they need to be highlighted and people need to really publicize these things
because I mean,
as you just described,
obviously most of us are,
uh,
horrified at those kind of events.
But people need to know,
I mean,
this has been going on in this country,
um,
for decades.
Yeah.
It seems like there's gotta be a way to balance it out too.
There's gotta be a way to take all of these industries that are profiting off of
it being illegal and locking people up and making sure there's no law
enforcement officers that are being paid.
There's gotta be a way to shift that into something else.
And until they do,
it's a hard road.
Well,
you know,
first of all,
we have to have the conversation,
dad.
Right?
It has to be a shift.
Like you're saying,
people are not even having that conversation.
People aren't having a conversation and say,
well,
what do we do with this machine that we built up over the separate past several
decades?
I mean,
I can think of a number of ways that we can,
uh,
use police officers,
in different roles than what they been used currently.
I mean,
I can think about the educational sort of thing,
but sometimes that's,
think about heroin.
People have been talking a lot about heroin overdose deaths and those sorts of
things.
Saying the heroin is cut or lace with some sort of other compound.
We can use our police forces,
for example,
whenever they confiscate something like heroin,
why not do the chemical analysis and make sure it's posted in those local
regions so people understand what the drug actually contain.
I mean,
we can have police outreach doing this sort of thing.
Okay,
you want to avoid this because this compound is dangerous.
We can do those kinds of things.
We never do.
They never tell the public what's actually in the compound.
If,
if something is in the compound,
they say that,
oh,
it's cut with something or why not tell the public who more likely to be
susceptible to obtain in that
type of heroin.
Completely agree.
But if you were on the bill O'Reilly show,
he'd be like,
you're just going to encourage those kids now they know what they can take and
what not to take.
You're going to,
you're going to do the testing for them.
Who's going to pay for that testing?
Our tax dollars are going to go to give them the exact recipe of their heroin
that they like.
So Bill O'reilly,
you know,
he was generous enough to have me on his show.
And so,
um,
uh,
so props to him for that.
But the thing about the bill O'Reilly show is that people should not get
twisted.
That is not news.
That is entertainment.
And the goal of what he's disseminating is not public education and not
necessarily for the public good.
So if you want to be entertained,
he's outstanding.
But if you actually want information,
you're in the wrong place.
Wait a minute,
man.
You didn't wash the thing about him talking about God making the tie go in and
it's how I go out and no one can explain it.
You didn't see that.
I watched that and I was like,
okay,
he's fucking trolling.
He's trolling.
He knows about gravity.
This is motherfuckers saying,
we can't explain why the tie goes in.
The tide goes out.
He knows.
They can explain that he's fucking with you.
Well,
I mean,
think about it.
The guys had the number one new shell quote unquote news in the United States
for about 15 1617 years.
And that's the formula that is used.
Why should he change?
Right.
So for him it's like he might as well be like Stephen Colbert.
He's playing a role.
Absolutely.
Just his role's not funny.
His role is just designed to scare the shit out of you and get,
you want to build bigger barns.
Well,
the thing about it is that you and I understand that he's playing a role and he
understands he's playing a role,
but all of these networks works
like that.
They're all playing a role.
And,
but the,
the thing is we just don't caricature them like we do him,
but they're all playing a role.
They bring in suits,
so called experts,
but they think that they're the expert.
And so all of these guys are playing a role.
It's entertainment.
It's not news.
And that's one thing that the public has to understand.
That's not news.
You can't,
I mean,
they give you news while they're giving you entertainment,
but you're absolutely right.
It's entertainment first.
Yeah.
That's why they're wearing skirts that barely cover their vaginas.
I mean,
those women on Fox News,
those are some of the hottest legs you could see on television.
And they're giving you the news and they're crossing their legs back and forth
when they're on the couch hypnotizing you.
You don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
Syria or Ukraine.
Who knows?
Look at her legs.
Why is her,
her legs are naked.
Like imagine if guys wore skirts and interviews will be the most ridiculous shit
ever.
But somehow or another,
you're allowed to see most of this woman's,
you know,
you,
she is actually attractive legs.
You should actually go to the network and tell them that,
or Beto nicely go and I,
I get tongue tied.
It wouldn't be able to talk.
Yeah,
it's,
it's hilarious.
I mean it's,
it's a,
it's a propaganda factory.
I mean it really is.
I mean,
it just trying to try to dance for you and get you to keep tuning in so they
could sell shampoo.
I mean,
all I know exactly,
but that's all we have.
I mean,
if it's,
if you don't go out and get your news on your own,
if you're one of those people that you get home from work and you turn a car and
you turn on the evening news and you sit in front of the dinner table and you
watch the evening news,
if that's the only way you get your information,
like wow,
we're fucked.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's why I'm a college professor.
To help.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess it,
but that is the future.
Like guys like you teaching young people so that they grow up in a day.
I mean,
I think they're growing up in a different environment.
Anyone doesn't think we're in a new moment man,
particularly as it comes as it relates to the drugs.
This is something that we haven't seen before and the young people today,
I mean you see it on Twitter,
I see it on Twitter.
Some of the comments and statements that people tweet at me,
I mean they are a lot more critical about this issue with that my generation
was,
and so I am deeply encouraged and so when I speak on this issue,
as you pointed out,
how frustrating it might be to deal with certain people.
I'm not really dealing with those people.
I'm really dealing with the future.
I'm speaking for history and that's really the only way you can change things.
Just to change the minds of the young people that are coming up.
The people that are set in their ways,
they already have their mortgages that they have to protect and that's,
yeah,
they can also justify that it's okay what they're doing because they've always
done it.
Other people are doing it and it's legal.
That's right.
So they don't think they're doing any wrong.
I had a friend who was a cop I did Jujitsu with.
He was always telling me,
hey,
if I don't give a fuck,
if they've got a medical marijuana license,
catch him with weed on busing them.
And I'm like,
dude,
you fucking listen to yourself.
You're a good guy.
Like why are you talking like that?
That's ridiculous.
You would take me,
aren't we friends?
You'd take me in,
you throw me in jail for no reason.
Just stupid.
That is what,
but your friend,
right?
You talking to your friend?
I'm sure he respects you.
So therefore he probably reevaluate what he just said.
I hope so.
I don't think so though.
He's fucking crazy that dude.
But he's a cop and you know,
he,
he just,
he thinks of it as us versus them.
You know,
he's got that mentality of us versus them and that when there's a law,
it allows that other person to be to them.
That's right.
If it's written down,
oh,
that's a them.
That's right.
I mean,
that also does,
I mean that's one of the things that happens when people are involved in legal
cases,
divorces,
you know,
disputes with their company.
It's us and them.
And we go into US versus them mode.
And cops are an US versus them mode when it comes to drugs.
They've lived their whole lives as police officers under the thinking that
someone who's got drugs is a perp and then they can get that guy.
And then that's something that they win.
They win,
the guy's in jail and they win.
That's right.
They dehumanize the person and so forth.
And that person isn't really a person.
And that's a problem.
That's a major problem.
I mean,
and,
and so you want to make sure that people,
we want to encourage people not to behave like that.
Yeah.
And it's gotta be really hard for the cops as well,
if this is what they've done always their entire career.
And then all of a sudden the laws change and they have to adjust.
Well,
so I was in the military,
you know,
we haven't talked about that.
And so I was a cop in the military for a short period of times.
And one of the things about cops that they're,
they're really good at,
they're really good at taking orders so they will adjust if it comes from the
top,
but it has,
the pressure has to be put on the top to make sure that the sort of rank and
file officers followed followed the these orders.
But they,
they,
they're really good at following orders.
They I,
I'm,
I'm sure they are.
I just would be concerned that it would take a long time to turn that battleship
of,
of intent around change the way they look at it.
Look at Colorado,
look at Washington,
right?
The amount of money that those folks are projected to make in terms of
taxpayer's money.
I assure you you're going to have former d a e agents involved in the marijuana
industry,
police officers involved in that industry relative relatively quickly.
So when you say it's going to take a long time,
no,
it won't take a long time.
All you have to do is just change to change the orders or to continue to see,
to continue to,
in this case,
money so you can actually do it if you have a commitment to doing it.
I,
I don't think it'll take a long term.
That's very optimistic.
When you look at Colorado and you look at Washington state,
do you think that the genie's out of the bottle and it's just going to spread?
Now the genie is out of the bottle and it will depend whether the genie stays
out of the bottle.
Depends on how much tax revenue is generated.
That's number one.
If Colorado continues to generate the revenue that they've been reporting
recently,
the genie's out of the bottle for a while.
Especially in this economy.
It's kind of a perfect storm,
right?
This screwed up economy when everything's all that's right,
especially in this accounting me,
but in the United States,
if you're making money,
that trumps everything,
right?
Hold on.
Freak fucking group of humans.
We are.
It's really strange,
but it's exciting.
I mean,
I hate the fact that the situation exists as it is.
I hate the fact that a g just as giant percentage of our population is in prison
for nonviolent crimes and involve personal choice and drug,
either drug use or even selling drugs.
It's,
it's unbelievably hypocritical when you have drugs everywhere you look.
But,
but at least I'm encouraged that I see this shift in the young people.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm very encouraged men and that's the thing that keeps me going.
That's the thing that keeps me on the road with this book,
talking to people about this issue of trying to educate people.
I mean,
um,
because I think that they're going to do it better than we did it.
And if I could play any role in helping them do it better,
let's do it.
What's been the biggest resistance that have all these years of studying drugs
and studying the reactions of drugs?
What do you,
what do you feel has been the biggest resistance of their biggest hurdle that
you've had to overcome?
Because I'm sure it must have been pretty difficult to get this going,
especially in the 90s.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
so when you say what's been the biggest hurdle to overcome?
I'm not sure if you mean professional hurt holder hurdle,
a personal hurdle.
Because you know,
in the book it's personal and professional and so it all kind of binds it all.
I'm not sure exactly
where you want to go with this.
Well either one either or.
But I what I meant is the resistance to your research.
Yeah.
So the resistance that a research,
uh,
the biggest sort of resistance has been primarily from law enforcement community
and treatment providers that those types of dose to communities in part because,
um,
I mean I understand that I'm messing with their money at some level.
Um,
but that's okay.
I expected that sort of thing.
And my major thing is that if I can just get people to focus on evidence,
the real evidence and not the hysteria,
not anecdotes I'll don't anecdotes on can be important.
If I can get people to focus on evidence,
I think I win them over.
Yeah.
I,
when I tell people how marijuana was initially made illegal,
they,
they look at me like I'm crazy.
Like I'm making things up and I give him the William Randolph Hearst story and
how they,
uh,
use this term marijuana that was a wild Mexican tobacco.
Like it wasn't,
and that the people that were making marijuana illegal didn't even know they
were making hemp illegal.
That's right.
Which had been used for thousands of years.
There was a product called the decorticator that was invented and when the
decorticator was invented,
it was a more effective way to process the hemp fiber.
And they were talking about hemp being a billion dollar crop.
It was on the cover of popular science.
And everybody was like,
well this is it.
You know,
ever hemp is going to make a new combat cause now there's a machine that allows
people to process it easy and they shut that shit down so quick.
And that was the original reason why marijuana,
it was illegal.
It had nothing to do with even a psychoactive form of it.
Well,
you just kind of talked about my book.
You know,
that's the sort of theme of the book is that when we talk about these drugs,
when we look from marijuana to heroin,
what we find is that the elect a legal legality of these drugs have less to do
with the pharmacology and more to do with these social and economic reasons that
you just laid out.
That's precisely it.
What's really interesting that there are laws in two states,
Colorado and Washington making marijuana legal.
But even though hamp has been non psychoactive and used in this country legally
since,
I mean,
you could buy it from Canada like we do with at [inaudible] and when you bring
it over and it's totally legal to possess,
but you can't grow it,
right.
They won't let you grow it.
Right.
Which is just unbelievable.
It's,
it's kind of hilarious and that's the real reason why marijuana is still illegal
to this day.
It was all done just to keep hemp out,
which is incredible.
Yeah.
So,
um,
there were,
and also one of the things that we have to understand too is that there is
always this sort of a,
the time when we made marijuana illegal,
um,
it was a time when the country didn't really want to have federal laws and so
you had to have a fuel.
And the fuel that we use was related to the Mexicans and black people using the
drug.
So there were a number of people who genuinely,
genuinely
believe that marijuana made these folks misbehave and engage in a heinous
crimes.
And so people thought that the drug was so awful that we,
we would,
that any responsible society would ban the drug.
So that component of,
of,
of banning drugs existed before marijuana.
That's why heroin opioids,
opiates were bad.
That's why cocaine was banned earlier.
So,
um,
yeah,
this,
this year I'm just,
song has been played over and over.
Um,
who financed the reefer madness?
Do you know,
um,
who financed reefer madness?
That's a tough question because I don't know all of the history related to it.
One of the things that I do know is that the bureau of narcotics headed up at
the time by Harry Anslinger.
His bureau got more money as a result of going at the marijuana or vilify
marijuana.
And so I know that played a big role in the,
the,
um,
driving of,
of,
of making marijuana illegal.
But in terms of the Hearst family,
that whole story line,
I know it slightly,
but I don't know it as well as I know the Harry Anslinger story.
If it was apparently it was originally financed by a church group under the
title tell your children.
And,
uh,
the film was intended to be shown to parents as a morality tale attempting to
teach them this from Wikipedia,
teach them about the dangers of cannabis use.
However,
soon after the film was shot,
it was purchased by producer Duane Asper,
who recut the film for distribution on the exploitation exploitation film
circuit beginning in 38,
1939.
And through the forties and fifties,
the film was rediscovered in the early seventies and gain new life as a satire
among advocates of cannabis policy reform.
So again,
it became about money.
It the camera guy who realized he could make some money scaring the shit out of
people and sell tickets to this movie.
Yeah.
But also understand now by this time when the film really became big 38.
So the drug was already illegal to drug became illegal and 37.
And so,
uh,
maybe the film was just capitalizing on the sort of mood at the time,
two of the country that people were scared.
It's a,
that's kind of interesting though,
that it was originally from a church group and then some dude who made money
exploiting these fears.
Then he started doing,
it's,
it's really kind of goes along with what we've been saying the whole time.
It's all about the money.
Follow the money,
follow the money.
I mean,
in many of these cases follow the money.
It's like we all have a price followed the money.
That's so disturbing though.
That's disturbing to hear for some people that it's all our entire societies be
engineered by money.
Well,
um,
you know,
it,
it's one of these things that you hope people behave in a moral fashion.
You know,
despite the fact that we have these sort of interest,
these monetary interest,
but,
uh,
if people are hearing
for the first time that it's about the money and well,
they are kind of lazy
to the Games,
so yeah,
it's sort of a Duh Duh.
What do you think about,
um,
I don't know if you've ever watched the a vanguard show,
uh,
the oxycontin express.
Did you ever see that episode?
No.
How about you?
Tell me about it.
I got a lot to say about oxycon please.
I tell me about notice show,
great show,
um,
about the,
uh,
pathway,
the highways between Florida and the rest of the country that Florida is drug
use in the oxycontin.
Prescriptions were so high.
I think Florida had some insane amount,
like more than the entire comp country combined by a long shot of oxycontin
prescriptions and people were going down to these pain management centers and
they documented the whole process.
Apparently Florida,
since this documentary has been forced to clean their act up because we talked
about it on the podcast and I got a lot of tweets from people with new
information.
It was pretty cool.
But they had these pain management centers that were built in,
they have a doctor and a pharmacy right there and my back hurts.
Here you go,
take this paper,
go right next door and get your heroin.
And then people would do it under like 15 different names.
They had no database.
So you'd go to one doctor and get a prescription and you go down the street and
go to another doctor and they weren't able to exchange information and find out
that this guy is Joe Rogan character has a hundred different prescriptions for
oxycontin and he's just driving around all day with a backache,
you know?
No,
no.
You know,
like that sort of thing.
Um,
I'm,
I'm happy that people are concerned about the over use of any drug,
for example.
But the thing that concerns me about the whole,
that sort of thing is that when you make these documentaries,
they,
they invariably,
they do poor jobs.
One of the reasons that they do poor jobs is because they highlight,
do you sort of aberrations to the worst case scenario?
And then so me,
the viewer,
or we get outraged because we see this abhorrent behavior that's going on.
And then what happens is that you get this cracked down so severe that people
who are in pain,
who actually need the medication find it difficult to get the medication.
So it'd be nice if we just had like our routine sort of policing of the,
all of these activities when we find that people are abusing the system we do
with it,
but not get x,
don't,
don't exaggerate our sort of punishment to the extent that we're doing more
harm.
So on the one hand folks,
if they are using Oxycontin,
I would much prefer them use oxycontin then that they use street heroin in part
because Oxycontin,
we know it's 100% pharmaceutical grade and the adulterants,
there are no adulterants in that oxycontin versus heroin where there are
adulterants in the street level heroin.
So on the one hand you have to think about we have to wait all of these sorts of
potential risks and benefits and oftentimes
it's a one sided story and that that bothers me.
Well,
one of the things they were talking about in the documentary was how Florida was
providing the rest of the country for,
with Oxycontin.
And that's why it was a big issue.
Sure.
I,
I'd like,
like I said,
I know that Florida had these issues and that's,
that's fine.
And the,
and the authorities should take care of it.
They should do what's appropriate.
But,
uh,
I hope they don't exaggerate it because typically that's what we do.
We go overboard.
Yeah.
That is one of the issues of a,
another article that I was reading on Bloomberg about these,
uh,
pain victims that were trapped in this prescription crackdown and that the
amount of oxycontin prescriptions has dropped dramatically,
dropped by 97% after a joint US state task force made 2,150 arrest for offenses
ranging from improper sales to overprescription by doctors.
Yeah.
Docs are afraid.
You know,
I mean,
th th th there are far more good doctors out there who are trying to be
responsible.
Then the way were ones that you described.
Uh,
and the ones who are trying to be responsible,
they'd say,
I'm not prescribing these pain meds because I know there's potential for too
much potential for risk or harm.
Their,
uh,
not so much from for the patient,
but for myself in terms of losing my license,
somebody may think that I'm doing this intentionally and so I worry about that,
uh,
how we,
crack down to severely.
Yeah.
This,
that's a,
the,
the whole point of this one article on Bloomberg and if anybody wants to check
it out,
that's the name of it.
A Florida pain victims trap by prescription crackdown.
It's under there.
A health section in 2010,
Florida had 90 of the nation's top 100 pharmacies buying oxycodone.
Wow.
Isn't that where a rush Limbaugh was getting his,
yeah,
he was popping some insane number two,
that fat fuck,
he was throwing down like a hundred a day where you got a lot of bulks thrown a,
you know,
and heroin through,
on the one hand it's like it's um,
there is,
there's so much.
They're number one,
he was on essentially heroin.
That's what Oxycontin is basically.
But yet he was going to work,
he was paying his taxes and he was hand in Lizard responsibilities,
right?
Yeah.
Nobody was,
nobody pointed this out.
And so when we think about drug users,
that's your
typical drug user.
Yeah,
that's a great example of it because I mean,
who better a guy who's anti-drugs,
who happened to be on drugs and a guy who's a,
a mouthpiece for the right wing machine,
which has always been anti quote unquote drugs.
And here's a guy who's taken fucking elephant size doses of this shit every day.
He's got his nanny out there running around or whoever it was,
his housekeeper running around out there at bargain,
more heroin farm and she got popped.
It's hilarious that that guy was like an antique truck guy.
I mean it's,
he's,
he's performing,
you know,
that's a show,
you
know this.
Yeah.
But it's fascinating that the,
those guys exist,
that the bill O'Reilly's the rush Limbaugh type characters,
the people that really are putting on an act and you know,
Stephen Colbert air,
everybody thinks of him as,
you know,
this,
uh,
it,
you know,
character richer,
caricature.
But they're all characatures.
Absolutely.
That's how they make their money.
And you look at rush the most house,
it's fucking giant.
It's huge.
People like what he does south there golfing everyday with a hearing aid now
cause he,
he apparently did so much oxycontin,
he fucked up his hearing.
You know,
don't blame that on oxicon plus with Alex Jones told me,
well then don't blame that on octacopter.
Alex Jones explained it to me and some pseudo medical term.
Now just,
we'll pair it right back at you though.
I mean,
you know,
when you,
when you say to kind of venom that,
that guy says,
you know,
somebody probably hit him upside,
but don't blame that on Oxycontin.
Is it possible to take so much oxycontin,
ego,
death?
I am not aware of that.
I and I,
I'm just not aware of that.
I,
yeah,
I would have to do the research here.
No,
I mean,
I have been studying this issue for a while and that just never,
ever heard of that.
So I only heard it because of Alex Jones.
I mean,
it's not the best.
It's not wicked.
He sent even Wikipedia,
he's great guy and everything,
but you go deaf.
Let's see,
let's see if it's true.
It's a punch that shit.
And we will live in strange times,
you know,
but all right,
really quickly,
uh,
he acknowledged he had gone almost completely deaf.
Nope.
Didn't,
he's not admitting it.
Who knows what it,
how much oxicon like what's the LD 50 for folks who don't know?
I'm LD.
50 is lethal dose.
50%.
So if you,
uh,
some drugs it's very high.
Some drugs,
it's very low marijuana.
It's insane.
I don't know what the LD 50 for Oxycontin is.
But one of the things about about heroin or just any other opiate like Aki
continents that if you've been using it for a while,
that means you can really increase your dose of the drug.
So,
you know,
I've seen heroin users take anywhere from 25 milligrams of that drug to 500
milligrams.
That's a why and be fine.
Uh,
and so it all depends on the,
the user's history of using the drug.
So he could,
uh,
I'm not surprised that Pete's been using a drug for a while that he was using
large doses.
That doesn't surprise me.
And that doesn't even concern me if he was using large doses,
if he had developed tolerance.
So if you develop tolerance and you're taking say 50 pills a day or whatever he
was taking,
that's no more dangerous than taking one or two pills a day if you don't have
the college for it.
See,
one of the things that people don't talk enough about in terms of drugs is sort
of protective effects of tolerance.
So when people develop tolerance to any drugs,
whether it be marijuana,
alcohol,
heroin,
it protects you from some of the toxic effects so you can push the dose without
having harmful effects.
Let me just give you an example from an animal study.
Just one of the things that we reported a that was reported in the literature
with laboratory animals and methamphetamine is that you give them a whopping
dose of that drug.
You can cause neurotoxic effects.
Brain cells die right now if you allow that animal to develop tolerance by
giving escalating doses over several days,
and then you give them that whopping dose you block to sort of neurotoxic oh
brain cell death as a result of them developing tolerance.
So tolerance is important to protect the animal from some of the toxic effects
of the drug.
That's fascinating.
So the LD 50 rate will absolutely change with those who are tolerant to it from
continued use.
Yeah,
so the w the lethal dose will look different based upon the user's history.
Okay.
So when they say like lethal dose,
50% or 50% of the population being,
you know like if you have 100 people and then you give them a certain amount of
heroin,
50% of them die as soon as they start taking that heroin,
that number changes.
That's right.
That number.
You know,
it's hard to predict when when we start talking about people who have tolerance,
I mean,
so when we think about the LD 50 we'd typically talking about folks who doesn't
do,
don't have experience with the drug,
and we do physically addict in some form to a lot of drugs that you were talking
about alcohol being one of the few that if you physically addicted to it and you
quit,
didn't that,
isn't that when it happened with Amy Winehouse?
Didn't they show that her system had nothing other than alcohol on it and
nothing but alcohol?
But I'm not sure how she died.
I don't know.
I don't want to get this wrong.
Folks do die that way though,
right?
Oh yeah.
You can die from alcohol withdrawal.
You die typically from seizures.
That's caused as a result of the alcohol withdrawal.
So if someone out there is addicted to alcohol,
how do they kick alcohol?
That they have to do it very slowly?
Yeah.
So if you develop dependence on alcohol,
you should probably be admitted to a hospital in order to receive business with
diazepines.
Uh,
something like Dad's a Pam of value,
um,
which acts in a similar way as alcohol,
but it's longer lasting.
So the body has a chance to detoxify.
The benzodiazepines slowly leaves the body,
whereas alcohol abruptly leaves to body.
And then that's what causes the seizure activity and those sorts of things.
What is the physiological effect of the alcohol leaving the body and then the
seizure?
Like what,
what causes it to the cause of the body to just,
so when,
um,
if you,
have you ever had a hangover?
Yes.
That's alcohol withdrawal.
So what Halle?
Yeah,
that's alcohol withdrawal.
Dehydration.
It's partly,
it's part of alcohol withdraw.
A dehydration is,
it's part of it as well.
But that's,
that's like the mild symptoms of alcohol withdrawal.
So,
but when you think about the severe sort of alcohol withdrawal that you're
asking about,
what happens with the seizure?
So the idea is that alcohol,
what it does is that it suppresses much of the brain activity,
much of the brain activity telling me,
man,
it is just suppressed.
And then for longterm
use of alcohol,
it really suppresses a number of brain cells.
And then all of a sudden,
because alcohol's Halflife to time in which half of the drug leaves,
the body is only about an hour.
It's really quick.
So the half life is so short.
Once the alcohol has left the body and it's been depressing the central nervous
system to brain activity.
Now all of a sudden dose,
dose,
dose cells fire wildly uncontrollably.
And that's what causes the seizure activity that's unbelieving,
really fascinating.
So it's also unbelievably fascinating that it's been proven that alcohol
actually suppresses the use of the mind that the mind can't work as well.
Well,
I don't want,
I don't want to say that strongly.
I,
it certainly depresses a certain,
uh,
neurons,
a number of neurons.
So like when you,
when you think about it,
when you are anxious,
if you're anxious and um,
and you have some alcohol,
if you have a Benzodiazepine,
it's suppressing certain type of activity.
And so that's a good thing and you might actually function better because if you
think about going to a party or having some event and then you still anxious
where you can't perform as well and you maybe have a drink and now you're calm
and you might actually be more social and you might actually perform more better
in that situation.
So I don't want to say that it,
uh,
that it's just sort of generalized a bad effect on your behavior or the brain.
So at certain low dosage it can be beneficial.
High dosages,
it does shut down certain functions of the brain.
Like there's very few people that would score as well on their sats after five
shots of Jack Daniels.
Yeah,
I think that,
um,
that's one of the thing,
we've been really good at public education and most people know that they
shouldn't do shots before taking the sats for that reason.
Right.
Do you imagine if it made you smarter?
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I can't imagine anything that makes you smarter besides studying and working
hard
for you.
That's a very good way to say that.
That's so true.
But,
um,
it,
it's interesting though,
when you think about the idea that this is one of the most popular,
if not the most popular recreational drug in the world.
Uh,
and one of the most popular,
the only big time sanctioned one in America where you don't have to have a
sickness.
Almost every drug that we have a,
that it's a prescription drug,
whether it's good for you or bad for you,
dangerous,
you know,
an incredibly potent,
whatever it is.
You have to get a prescription.
It has to be a reason for it.
You don't need a reason to get fucked up on booze.
He just,
there's Mikey's bar and you walk on it and give me a double on a beer and then
boom,
20 minutes later you're drunk,
you know,
and we don't need any,
no reasons,
no doctor.
And nobody has to hold your hand.
You don't have to write anything down.
You don't have to give the guy your name and phone number and I'm trying to
figure out are you saying that's a bad thing or good thing fascinated by it.
I mean I'm neither,
I'm not saying it's a good or a bad thing.
I if I had to say should it be legal or illegal?
I would say absolutely legal.
We,
I,
I've enjoyed alcohol many times in my life.
I don't have a problem with alcohol but it is very telling and that that is the
one drug that we chose.
Well it is for a number of
reasons.
Um,
I mean when you think about it,
how we do alcohol,
we take it orally and so it's the only drug that we take orally that you can
feel the effects almost immediately.
And so when you were at a party,
you don't have to wait for the onset of the effects that happen.
It happens almost immediately and you control the intoxication simply by taking
more or less of the drug can't do that with other drugs orally.
And so the f a and that's one reason that that's it,
that that's the case is because alcohol essentially has no barrier blood brain
barrier.
Like those other drugs,
they have to cross the blame blood brain barrier.
What alcohol.
There are essentially no barrier for alcohol.
So you can the pharmacokinetics or pharmacology properties of the drug makes it
very convenient for a recreational drug.
That's,
that's another important reason that it's legal.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
Can you consider like if you were going to open up like a mushroom store and
everybody come in and saw mushrooms,
you'd give him the mushrooms and be like,
come back and hang out in an hour and 20 minutes because for the next hour,
you know,
nothing really is going to happen.
You're going to start sweating,
you know,
um,
but alcohol,
one shot to shot,
you're feeling it,
you're doing it,
do the oral route.
So when you take a drug orally,
some of it will be broken down before it reaches the brain,
which is the good thing because that means that you don't have such large doses
being shot into your vein or smoked.
And your lungs until the brain.
And so it's kind of protective in that way.
And so those from a pharmacology properties,
just a,
I can't think of another drug that has such good progress.
Yeah,
I couldn't think of another drug either.
But if you,
if you were doing marijuana,
the issue would be that you would get people around you high as well through
secondhand intoxication.
Well,
it's not only that you have to actually smoke it,
but were there are better methods now you got vaporizers and that sort of thing.
So you can smoke marijuana more discretely.
And as the sort of methods,
uh,
our develop,
it might become a more social drug,
but we still have the issue of getting large amounts into the bloodstream,
therefore into the brain in such a rapid success.
And,
and that's the thing that worries us in terms of safety.
And so people need to be able to need to be educated on how to make sure that
they don't take too much of a large dose,
um,
at once.
And once you do that,
you can help people be safe.
But alcohol,
they'll have so much worry about it.
The thing that we try and prevent people from doing this binge drinking because
of having large amounts in such a rapid amount of time that it just,
your body can't process it quickly now.
Yeah.
It's just,
well,
you know,
toxicity occurs primarily because of the large amount at a rapid sensation,
a rapid sort of,
uh,
in rapid order.
But what about,
well,
I mean the other big issue with alcohol as opposed to marijuana is coordination,
uh,
drastically affects coordination drastically affects your ability to move
correctly.
Your Response Times.
Yeah.
Well it all depends dose again,
you know,
so it all depends how much people are taking,
like all of these drugs.
One of the things I try and point out,
the most important thing about drugs is dose.
You know,
as you increase the dose,
you increase the likelihood of toxicity because there are doses in which you can
take all of these drugs safely and accomplish whatever task you're trying to
accomplish.
But it's all about dose.
So when we say general statements about what alcohol does it,
what cocaine does,
we have to be cognizant of dose
about drinking and driving though.
What is the,
uh,
the,
when you see the,
um,
the limits,
I don't remember what,
what are,
what are the current national limits?
You know,
they've married a little bit and I actually think they loan them,
lowered them in certain places.
Do you think that they're fair where they're at right now?
Do you think they should be adjusted?
What are,
what are your thoughts?
No,
I think they're fair.
I mean,
they're the best we can do.
And then we,
we also have,
those were roadside tests and those kinds of things.
It's the best that we can do.
And I,
I think we're doing a really good job at sort of a alcohol related drinking.
Uh,
I mean,
driving problems when we look at what issues we had in 1960s compared to what we
have now,
the number of accidents and deaths related to driving hab dramatically
decreased.
All those sorts of things,
in part because of our education,
because of what we're doing.
Um,
so I think we're,
we're,
we're going about that,
uh,
quite well and appropriate.
What about tolerance?
Yeah.
In relates to that,
because for a person who doesn't drink at all,
if they have a point,
whatever,
and then you get some dude who's just hitting it hard every night and he's only
had one or two beers,
but if he gets pulled over,
he's going to,
he's going to test too high.
But his tolerance might be so that he would be fine.
You're absolutely right.
And that's one thing that these sort of,
um,
uh,
criteria don't account for his tolerance,
but I'm a good lawyer who has to defend.
Someone should probably bring in tolerance,
uh,
particularly if their client is tolerant to the alcohol effects.
But good luck.
That's a tough one because people think that they have this deaf definite
measure and it tells them something and it really doesn't without understanding
tolerance.
But you're absolutely right.
That's a great question.
So a universal number like that,
it's an inherently on scientific knowing and understanding
a universal number like that is not,
it does not apply to everyone.
It does not consider tolerance.
That's right,
but it's the best that we have currently other than,
you know,
the hand eye coordination drills.
That's all right.
Those are,
that's the thing.
It's the behavioral tests that are important.
You want to see how impaired behaviorly impaired to person is.
Um,
because if you have that in combination with the blood levels,
then you,
you have an confidence of what you're seeing.
But if you have,
for example,
somebody testing over the limit based on their blood,
but their hand coordination,
they pass a sobriety test,
then you're less confident in what that blood level means.
Right.
That makes sense.
Is it,
is there any other variables as far as like a person's ability to pass a hand
eye coordination test when they're drunk?
I mean that flick ability,
things along those lines because some people they could barely bend down to
touch their shoes,
whereas other people are yoga masters.
If you've got a yoga master fucked up and you know,
you might be able to just put his foot over his head while he's hammered and the
cops be like,
this guy's sober.
Well that's right.
You know,
if people have practice with the test and they know how to do it really well,
um,
then maybe they are,
they're not impaired driving as well.
I don't know.
But yeah.
But all of those issues that you bring up,
man,
do are,
those are complex issues and those issues that the society has to struggle with,
but they won't do struggle with it because it's too complicated and it's just
nicer to have a number.
No.
How does a state like Florida become this weird aberration?
How's the state like Florida have?
So mainly they said 90% of all the,
uh,
oxycodone pharmacies,
the pharmacies that are making it and selling it.
How,
how does that happen?
How does one stage just go haywire?
You know,
I don't know the Florida law,
but I'm sure it's related to the purse.
I'm sorry.
Does,
so the permissiveness of their law.
I think that that's the thing that contributed to this.
I mean,
they probably were allowed to set up pain clinics in a way that,
uh,
you didn't require a much sort of oversight.
And then,
um,
so,
uh,
whenever those kinds of things happen,
you know,
there's a,
a potential for abuse.
And so I,
I would suggest,
I would probably guess that's what happened.
I was also wondering if maybe it might be some of the remnants of the cocaine
era of Miami about how,
did you ever see cocaine cowboys?
You ever see that documentary?
Yeah.
I'm from Miami,
so,
okay.
Cocaine cowboys and cocaine cowboys to,
uh,
shout out to my friend Billy Corbin who made those movies.
I met that dude.
Very nice guy and a really,
really fascinating documentaries that cover the whole cocaine,
um,
era of Miami where one year the graduating class,
the police academy,
every single member either wound up dead from murder or in jail for corruption.
Like they were just crazy and making money off of coke and coke is moving in and
out.
And I had always wondered if maybe that had something to do with like Sorta the
echoes of this,
a pervasiveness of drugs in that state.
Wow.
Man.
You know,
I haven't lived in Miami,
Florida since 1984.
Uh,
Florida is a bizarre state in general,
you know,
so I,
I have to,
do,
I have to say that I'm,
I'm,
I'm outside of the scope of my expertise when it comes to trying to understand
Florida.
I don't,
I don't understand Florida.
Well,
they said that there's more
banks per capita in Miami than any other city in the country.
And that is directly related to their ability to process money.
That was Koch money.
Yeah.
I mean,
I grew up in that area or you know,
the late seventies and early eighties and the Scarface era,
you know,
1980 was a peak murder rate in this country.
You know,
one of the highest murder rates was in 1980 in part because of the cocaine.
So to thing mind you long before crack,
but nobody's really talking about that.
Um,
and so yeah,
I know that era.
Uh,
and I know that cocaine was a big deal in Miami,
but my friend Steve did his residency in Miami and,
uh,
it was during that era and he just got just crazy stories of violence of,
of just people coming in and just all fucked up.
And it was,
a lot of it was drug wars.
Yeah.
Well how did that all of a sudden happened?
Do you know the history,
new drug markets,
you know,
it,
how did these drug markets opened up mean what took so long that it took to the
1980s for them to get over here?
Well,
I think,
well,
the story that I heard and I haven't researched as to the best of my ability,
so this is only what I've read superficially is that a,
there was a crackdown on marijuana,
a big crackdown in the 70s on marijuana.
And then so the drug cartels brought in cocaine because it was smaller way and
you can make more money.
And then,
so that was about the time when cocaine started to flood the u s markets.
Um,
that's what I've read as far as that goes.
But like I said,
it's a superficial read of my understanding of it.
So really all crack cocaine was,
was like the second wave of cocaine.
It's like cocaine came when they figured out there's a,
an opening because of marijuana crackdowns.
And then they said,
well,
we've got to figure out a way to get it to people that can't afford to buy a
brick.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Some industries to a dealer figured out how to cook cocaine and produce mass,
produce it in ways that people could smoke it at cheap unit doses.
I mean,
that's,
that's brilliant quite frankly.
Um,
that is when you think about it that way,
you know,
but that person is brilliant.
Whereas whoever rig the laws in Florida to allow oxycontin's to come in and,
you know,
the,
we look at that and we go,
well,
this person a,
this is corruption.
You know,
this is a,
this is what they've done is terrible.
Well,
you know,
uh,
I don't know the law,
so it's hard for me to speak on the specifics of that.
But,
um,
and so,
I don't know.
I don't know,
the person could have had a great idea and probably meant,
well I don't know,
but it certainly doesn't seem to be playing out as well as we would have liked.
Now when you start to do these studies and uh,
you know,
you're in the 1990s and you're,
you're finding things that are contradictory to what we normally consider to be
the culturally accepted ideas about these drugs.
Um,
what,
what happens,
do you get resistance from people in,
in universities to get resistance from your peers?
No.
Um,
you know,
uh,
how science works is that you publish these stories.
One,
one study doesn't mean as much as multiple studies and so you publish one study
and it's like,
that's a great finding.
Cool.
And I see if you can replicate it,
let's see if you can extend it.
Let's see if other people can replicate it.
And if other people can replicate it,
you can extend the findings now you feel more confident in what you're finding.
And so that,
that's kind of what happened over the years.
I build,
I build on my findings and in an increased my confidence,
so much so that I thought that I should write a book in order to make sure the
public understands what's happening.
Because when you publish in the scientific literature,
five people read your paper.
If you're lucky,
you know,
people there,
there's not many people who read the literature.
Um,
besides those few people who are interested in your area.
And so as I increased my confidence in the findings,
I thought I wanted to publicize it because I thought what we were doing with
drugs was inconsistent in terms of policy and the way we educate and treat drugs
was inconsistent with the science.
And the way that you communicate with the people was to write a book,
a trade book.
Now,
how's this book been received?
Have,
is there any,
like if you have a debate about it,
is anybody ever said,
I challenge you on your ideas?
These are not correct.
This is not true.
Have you ever had to like sit down with Ann Coulter or anything along those
lines?
Well,
I don't think she's qualified.
That'd be challenging me quite frankly,
about drugs.
Um,
but she would do it anyway.
Yeah,
I know.
She might embarrass herself if she did I show you.
Um,
but,
um,
uh,
they're happening as possible.
There have been people who,
uh,
who may say that they have some trouble with the conclusions that I draw,
but the scientific community and the general public have been welcoming and it's
been a breath of fresh air for most people because people already know this.
The things that I'm saying about drugs like the fact that the vast majority of
people who use drugs are not drug addicts.
That's not really that groundbreaking to people who actually know drugs and
people who are critical.
That's not groundbreaking.
Um,
what's,
what's
groundbreaking is that it's being said in a public forum because it's never been
said in a public forum.
It's always been the exact opposite.
It's always been the propaganda.
And what's really refreshing about what you're doing is the fact that you are
pushing fact first regardless of how it's going to be accepted.
That you're just saying,
look,
this is,
I'm a scientist.
This is what's going on.
And we have to really accept that in order to figure out what we're dealing
with.
Yeah,
man.
You know,
science actually saved me.
I mean the data,
the focus on what do the data say saved my life and you know,
without science I'm not here and all I can,
I mean there are people who are smarter than me.
There are people who are more articulate than me.
There are people who are more wealthy than I am,
but the great equalizer are the data.
Whatever the data says is the position that I take and as long as I do that,
I'm okay.
I can do,
I can say anything publicly,
I can be in public.
I don't,
nothing intimidates me as long as I am on the side of the data.
Yeah,
that's,
that is so important and that's not what's been thrown around.
It's been what ideology do you prescribe to what,
you know,
what,
what is,
what are your thoughts on freewill?
What are your thoughts on the person's ability to handle certain things and
other people can't?
That's what the discussion has always been more almost more philosophical.
Yeah.
I know as long as discussion is at that level and,
and now we can engage in this exchange of ignorance.
And that's what we've had,
you know.
So in this case,
what we,
when I'm trying to do is make sure we avoid to exchanges of ignorance and making
sure that people engage in this conversation,
that they have some expertise,
some skills,
some knowledge,
and not just some emotion.
Now in a perfect world,
would drugs be decriminalized or would they be legalized?
Yeah,
so in high price in the book,
I argued that all drugs should be decriminalized.
Um,
I say they should be decriminalized and then we should have this corresponding
increase in realistic education.
Now when things are decriminalized,
then that means that people can be fined.
That's right.
They,
they may be subjected to fines.
You don't necessarily have to be fine too,
but just like a traffic violation,
you might get a fine or you may not get a fine.
Um,
but the,
the one thing that's important here is that they don't,
they don't go to jail and they don't ruin their lives as a result of having a
felony conviction.
Because when we think about the last three,
President Barack Obama,
George Bush,
Bill Clinton,
all three of those guys used illegal drugs.
Um,
uh,
Clinton,
marijuana,
Bush marijuana,
he's widely suspected abusing cocaine.
Obama used marijuana and cocaine.
All I'm saying is that let's make sure that the society has,
everybody in the society has the same opportunities.
It's those guys.
Now I'm in a decriminalized situation as opposed to a legal situation.
How do we decide where the revenue comes from as far as like tickets?
Isn't that an issue when,
cause then it becomes a money thing again?
Yeah.
You can charge people at ticket for having marijuana marijuana's decriminalized
and all a sudden we're getting tickets left and right for weed.
It's like a speeding thing.
Like it's like putting a 25 mile an hour speed limit on the highway when you
know everyone's going to break it.
Yes.
No,
no,
no.
That's exactly right.
And so that's where we have to be smart as a society in terms of thinking about
the administrative fees or fines that we would charge people.
Well,
we set limits to make sure that we don't become excessive.
For example,
the,
the greatest amount of fine you can give someone,
let's just say it's $25 or some amount that is not prohibitive and an amount
that they,
that police departments can't depend upon for their budgets and that money
shouldn't be allowed to be used to support police budgets.
That's an interesting way of doing it.
Are you completely opposed to legalization?
No,
no,
no.
I mean I am not completely opposed to legalization.
Mind concern here is that uh,
the country were too ignorant right now for legalization.
Not that people will go out and do some dangerous things related to drugs,
but if you legalize drugs,
now what will happen is that you will have the detractors say things like any
ILS in a society has got to be blamed on a drug and were so ignorant.
We're susceptible to believing that.
So before legalization,
I'm arguing that we have this increase in education about what drugs do and
don't do,
do.
So people cannot be susceptible to being hoodwinked like that.
Um,
I'm arguing that the education provides an inoculation.
If you will.
So you're saying we can't handle the truth.
Essentially,
where are you saying is that we need this decriminalization step before we get
to a legalization that it's,
that we couldn't just jump right into legalization.
It will be too much change.
Pandemonium.
People go crazy.
Fear.
People would use propaganda to set people against the,
you know,
to go against it.
Yeah.
So I'm thinking about,
well I'm,
I'm not saying it will be pandemonium.
We have Washington and Colorado right now.
Mark my words,
there will be studies coming out of Washington and Colorado showing that young
people in those states do more poorly on whatever measure you want to have as a
result of marijuana.
The studies,
the data won't support that conclusion,
but that's what people were going to be drawing from those data.
And so I'm,
this is my prediction right now as a result of people's ignorance about
marijuana.
And that's,
that's marijuana.
A drug that we have a lot more experienced and what heroin and but mark my
words,
you'll see those studies come out
now.
Isn't it problematic that marijuana is legal in two states medically legal?
And more like 18 or something now.
Something crazy at 17 or 18.
Yeah.
But still a schedule one substance,
which means that it has no medicinal value.
Whereas for folks who don't know,
heroin and cocaine are both scheduled to um,
which is kind of silly.
Scheduled one also includes all of the nonlethal psychedelic variants like
silicide in which the LD 50 rated something fucking crazy marijuana.
It's like 1500 pounds inside of 15 minutes.
Like,
yeah.
So it'd be clear heroin is a schedule one drug not scheduled to what is,
what is scheduled to methamphetamine is scheduled to scheduled to as
methamphetamine,
cocaine scheduled to cocaine scheduled to morphine is scheduled to.
So how do they get oxycontin's and then if a schedule to that,
those are scheduled too.
But it's heroin.
Yeah,
it's an opiate.
They Act at the same brain receptor.
So your,
your,
uh,
your puzzle look,
just the kind of explains or it typifies a Americans drug education.
Could you,
you were bright when you set,
but it's heroin.
Exactly.
But a better analogy is that morphine and heroin are essentially the same drug.
Like I explained the difference between crack and powder.
That's morphine and heroin.
Well that's why I was,
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
So morphine,
heroin is just morphine would an acid group attached to it?
They're the same drug.
And so the fact that drugs are legal,
you and I talked about this early,
earlier has less to do with the drugs,
biological activity of pharmacology and more to do with the social conditions
that were surrounding,
um,
uh,
the,
the legality of the drug more so than pharmacology.
That's interesting.
So,
uh,
cocaine,
which is a schedule two is crack a schedule one crack is a schedule one.
Yes.
Oh,
I get squirrely,
doesn't it?
That's right.
That's very squarely so heroin,
crack,
bad.
Oxycotton and you know,
all the other variance.
Yeah.
Okay.
The thing people have to understand that,
that these schedules are largely based on politics.
There are more political than pharmacology.
I'll do,
we say that they're largely based on pharmacology,
but some of this stuff,
as you're pointing out,
the inconsistencies in our logic and you don't even study this,
you just are just pointing this out and you can see the flaws in our thinking
and you're absolutely right.
So the scheduling thing is largely sociopolitical.
Yeah.
Cultural.
That's fascinating.
I had always assumed that heroin was scheduled to just because I knew that
oxycontin's were prescribed.
I didn't know.
And then the crack that the whole thing totally makes sense.
What is the additional,
the medicinal use of cocaine?
Cause there's medicinal cocaine.
Yeah.
Think about it.
If you've ever gone to a dentist,
right?
You might've had novacane put on your gums without cocaine.
You don't have novacane because cocaine was the first local anesthetic,
right?
That's one.
But cocaine today,
it's used primarily in minor surgeries in order to restrict the blood flow so
people can operate in that environment.
That's what it's mainly,
yeah.
Useful.
So a Lidocaine also related to cocaine.
Cocaine is related to cocaine.
That's right.
I had my nose fixed and they uh,
through some lidocaine up there and they,
you know,
they had the packing up there and then they spray lie to cane and I was fucked
up all day,
man.
I mean it was a weird feeling.
Like I wasn't high,
you know,
it wasn't like a cocaine high,
but I was like,
wow,
I don't feel good.
And I knew it was that line of Cain Shit.
I was like,
I,
I think I would rather have just felt the pain and to have all this weird stuff
in my system,
you know?
Yeah.
But yeah,
without,
without cocaine you don't have the local anesthetic properties apply to came
because it's a modification,
the cocaine structure.
Now,
how difficult would it be to get these drugs that have these insane LD 50 rates
and have a wealth of met medicinal benefits like marijuana and get them out of
schedule one?
I think marijuana,
there was a lot of movement now for marijuana to be moved away from schedule one
to schedule two.
Um,
I think if,
if the public continues,
it's pressure,
I think it will happen.
But the public has to be vigilant and they have to continue.
It's a activity and intensity,
otherwise they won't be,
it won't happen,
you know,
like,
um,
we sometimes think that these things are based mainly on medicine and medical
community,
scientific community.
The public has an important role to play here.
So
public opinion and public,
the,
the tide,
which way the tide is going is very important.
Yes.
Now when,
when you have something like,
uh,
like,
like marijuana that doesn't hurt people,
that doesn't kill people.
And then you hear like you'll hear on TV,
people come on and start talking about withdrawal symptoms and,
and people that have withdrawals from marijuana.
Are there physical withdrawals from marijuana?
Is it possible?
Yeah,
I think I'd published maybe along with my colleagues,
maybe 10 papers on marijuana withdrawal.
And so we have actually shown a demonstrated marijuana withdrawal now I should
say,
in order to see marijuana withdrawal,
you have to have people who smoked a drug every day,
damn near every day and multiple joints per day and then you are abruptly
stopped them.
Now you don't see marijuana withdrawal than everyone,
but you certainly can see some marijuana withdrawal to some people.
And when I say marijuana withdrawal,
it's about like nicotine withdrawal.
You know,
people,
uh,
they have sleep disruptions,
they have eating disruptions,
they are more moody,
these are more psychological sort of issues.
Um,
certainly not,
not life threatening.
Um,
but,
uh,
it's unpleasant.
You know,
if you can think about having withdrawal from tobacco,
you probably have a,
you have a good idea of marijuana withdrawal.
So it would be as strong as tobacco Raul,
because tobacco withdrawals a huge one.
Like oftentimes it's,
it's connected to being as bad as,
as heroin.
Well that's,
that's an exaggeration.
Yeah.
Goddamn cigarette smokers pictures.
Yeah,
that's an exaggeration.
And now when we think about,
again,
when I want to emphasize,
when we think about marijuana withdraw,
it's only seen in the heaviest users and is not seen and even all of the heavy
users.
And so it's something that you certainly can observe,
but it's not common.
And
so when you talk about these absolutely extreme versions of people that are
smoking multiple joints a day every day,
and then they stopped abruptly,
then they just feel like shit for a little while.
That's it.
That's all right.
No danger.
No,
I mean your,
your,
you'll be fine.
There wasn't,
you're not in any physical danger is part of it your
brain just scrambling because all of a sudden it's not high anymore and you're
like,
what are we doing?
What the fuck is going on here?
Like maybe that's the better way to put it.
You know,
I was just trying to think of some scientific way of saying,
but I think that that might be a better way of just saying,
you know,
um,
well think about it this way.
Whenever you engage in some activity heavily for some extended period of time
and then you abruptly stopped,
you know,
your body,
particularly when you think take in some substance,
your body adjusts to that substance being there and now that substance is
abruptly removed and now all the compensatory mechanisms in your body and your
brain are overactive.
And so that's part of the reason that you have the withdrawal symptoms.
But eventually the body resets and goes back to his homeostasis.
It's normal sort of balance except an extreme examples like alcohol where your
body desire,
you have to,
you have to do something to gap alcohol.
It's too dry,
too traumatic.
I mean,
wha when marijuana,
one of the nice things about marijuana is that it stays in the body relatively
long.
So to halflife of marijuana can be as much as 24 hours.
Now that's,
that allows the body to slowly detoxify.
Whereas what alcohol,
it's gone within an hour and it's like this abrupt shutoff,
you're shut off.
And now all of these compensatory Mekesen mechanisms are hyperactive and uh,
whereas what marijuana,
these compensatory mechanisms are active,
but they have an opportunity to slowly adjust.
That's fascinating.
So that's such a,
that's such a unique piece of information,
uh,
that the hangover effect is a withdraw from alcohol effect.
Yup.
I had always thought that it was just dehydration,
but I always wonder like,
why is it so strong?
Like you got to get really fucking dehydrated to get the kind of feeling that
you get when you have a hangover.
Yep.
Particularly,
you know,
and just think about it,
you put a in all this alcohol in your system,
people who have hangovers,
all this alcohol,
and as you get older,
you don't need a pump that much in department,
all of this alcohol in your system.
Then all of a sudden it's gone.
It stopped.
And then your body was just adjusting to the drug being there.
So compensatory mechanisms are really,
that's the,
that's the mechanisms behind the addiction that you're trying to,
when he introduced the drug to keep those compensatory mechanisms satisfied.
No.
Let me try it.
Let me,
how can I think of it?
Like I say,
if this thing about heroin,
that's an easier one for me.
We think about heroin.
One of the things the heroin is really good at,
and it's used medically for this reason,
it had been used medically for this reason is that it stops diarrhea.
So people who have a diarrhea that can cause death,
for example,
you give them heroin,
it makes you constipated.
That's a compensatory mechanism,
uh,
of,
of heroin,
right?
So,
uh,
that's a,
that's a compensatory mechanism of the body having it.
What,
I'm sorry,
compensatory mechanism of the body is that it tries to counteract
the sort of,
uh,
um,
constipation that heroin causes.
So it has to get the juices flowing again,
if you would.
The body tries to do that when the heroine abruptly leaves.
These overactive mechanisms now causes someone to have diarrhea because it was
trying to get the system going.
So the body is just trying to,
could correct itself to be where you need to be because you need to go to the
bathroom and the body is trying to make sure that happens because heroin is
blocking that ability to do that.
So that's
absolutely fascinating.
Now,
when you do heroin for long periods of time,
like how long does it take for these compensatory mechanisms to really set into
the point where you hit it withdrawal syndrome,
um,
for heroin,
it all depends.
So like if you only are using the drug in the mid intermediate meant Hudley uh,
you don't have to worry about the body becoming the compensatory mechanism
becoming so active that you have to worry about withdrawal symptoms.
It's only when it's the constant sort of,
uh,
administration of the drug constant,
levels of the drug in the body that the body compensatory mechanism become
hyperactive.
Is that the case with cigarettes as well?
Because you ever see that movie the insider with Russell Crowe where I did,
it was funny.
It was a calm,
no,
no.
The guy worked at a cigarette company,
you know,
scientists know,
I know it's when you're talking about it was one,
they did a,
it was based on the 60 minute interviews and that sort of thing.
Right?
The 60 minutes then.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It was all the guy who was talking about the 500 plus different chemicals that
the uh,
the government allows them to put in cigarettes that are all directly related to
addictive.
Yeah.
I mean,
well tobacco has about 4,000 chemicals in it.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Um,
well to natural tobacco or natural tobacco.
Okay,
so natural tobacco,
it's 4,000 natural chemicals.
About 4,000.
Yeah.
The additional chemicals that the,
uh,
cigarette companies put in,
which is what this scientist was highlighting the,
the guy who Russell Crowe played.
Um,
what,
what's going on there?
Like how were they able to do that?
Like when they're,
they're adding these things to cigarettes that make it so that you become more
addicted more quickly.
How are they doing that?
What are they doing?
You know,
there have been so much said,
for example,
there are co co chemicals that I understand that they were trying to add to
tobacco to make it more readily bleed released two more readily released a
nicotine.
Um,
um,
uh,
there,
there are chemicals being added to the back of for flavoring.
They say,
um,
there are a variety of sort of things.
Um,
but I don't know exactly what you're getting at it in terms of um,
uh,
why they add the,
the compounds in terms of addicting people.
Well,
this is just from what I got from that movie.
The movie Russell Crowe plays this scientist who's testifying about how they had
designed cigarettes to be much more Dick.
Yeah.
Uh,
so one of the things that,
I think it was illegal to manipulate the nicotine content in the tobacco
cigarettes because the tobacco company said that tobacco is a natural product,
you know,
so they don't do any manipulations.
That was one of the things,
but then it was found out that they had,
they had been growing,
does high ta dis high nicotine strain,
a tobacco and somewhere in South America.
And so that was one of those sort of issues,
uh,
related to this.
Um,
the tobacco company understands pharmacology or they understood pharmacology in
terms of designing the cigarette.
And the goal,
one of the major goals is that if you want to get someone addicted to a drug
like tobacco or nicotine,
is that you want to make sure you can release the nicotine in a more,
in a rapid,
efficient way to hit the long until the brain.
And I think the argument was that tobacco had figured out how to release the
nicotine more rapidly.
Um,
and then one of the major theories in addiction work is that the more rapidly a
drug has the brain,
the more addicted the drug is.
And so I don't know of if all of that has been demonstrated,
but I know a lot of this has been said,
but I don't know what has actually been demonstrated,
um,
in terms of what's a tobacco company did and what,
what,
uh,
scientists say
what?
So it's,
it's all in dose and frequency and that's how the compensatory mechanisms get
set off.
And so even heroin,
which we've all thought that you can't do once you'll,
you'll go,
man,
they'll get you.
You can and you could probably do it twice,
but you can't do it every week.
Yeah,
man,
do it like everyday for a couple weeks.
If anybody out there have taken Vicodin,
Percocet,
Oxycontin,
all of those drugs.
You've taken those drugs for pain or whatever reason,
and then you,
your pain is over and you go back to your life and you do your thing.
You have essentially taken a low dose of heroin.
And so the notion that someone can't take heroin more than once without becoming
addicted.
That's just Voodoo.
That's silly.
That's 1937
but what about people that do take pills and I have a relative and he hurt his
back.
He was a construction worker,
hurt his back,
started taking pain pills and became fucking a dunk.
A total junky.
Yeah,
he was responsible.
You had a family got divorced.
One of being this crazy liar pill popper dude.
Like what's that?
Yeah.
Those are the toughest questions that people ask me.
Right?
Because on the one hand it's like it's not the drug.
I show you that.
So when you talk about him becoming a liar and becoming all these kinds of
things,
I don't know the guy,
but the fact is is that we know that people do become dependent on these drugs
for whatever reason.
I don't know whatever the reason was for him,
but there could be a variety of reasons.
A lot of times people become addicted on these drugs because they have car
occurring,
co-occurring psychiatric disorders because they have lack of other op better
options because they have other issues that's going on.
I don't know,
but I have to like,
uh,
understand disguise complete situation.
Um,
but it's a fact that people do become addicted.
Some people,
but the vast majority don't.
So we can't blame the drug.
What we need to do is more systematically understand what's going on with that
person and then we can figure out what's going on.
Yeah.
That's so important when you just said,
because it's always a,
I mean,
what I just did,
I gave you this anecdotal story about this guy.
Well,
I know a guy ruined his life and then,
you know,
well,
maybe it would've ruined his life anyway and he would have you use a fucking
idiot.
I know the guy just so you're dead,
right?
Yeah.
Your observation is correct.
He was always looking for an excuse his whole life.
You know,
if you had to run seven laps,
he would run six and pull his ankle.
I've got to sit down,
he's just that guy.
And then,
you know,
he listened to the shelf,
does tough shit,
bitch.
You know,
you are,
he is what he is,
you know,
it's not good for everybody else.
If you try to,
you know,
baby fuck them.
You got to do what you gotta do that,
that guy,
you know,
was always that guy.
And so when he got hooked on pills and you know,
blames his whole life on pills.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's the thing,
that's,
that's one of the things that frustrates me in this sort of mission to educate
the public,
is that people blame drugs for their,
uh,
for some of their shortcomings in some of the things that are not their
shortcomings.
It's not their fault.
Um,
but we don't get to figure out what's really going on when you simply blamed the
drug.
So there are two crimes that are committed in that case.
We don't get to figure out what's going on your situation and then you're
restricting access to the drug for other people who may do it and need it
responsibly.
And also it's an incredibly complex discussion and we're breaking it down to
these very simple terms that may or may not apply.
Uh,
my friend who I told you about that had a problem with heroin who,
uh,
came over to my house to detox his family was crazy.
He was,
he was,
I when I,
you know,
got to know him better and I sort of understood his family's medical history.
I understood what was going on.
He was self medicating.
He,
there was a psychiatric issue in his family and it was not just one person.
So he,
this guy was self medicating.
And I think that's often the case.
And I think that's one of the great tragedies of a,
what happened during the Reagan administration when they started releasing
people out of the streets,
homeless people that were interned before that they were in mental institutions
and they changed what defines a person is mentally incompetent and like lucky
wipe your own ass.
Can you feed yourself,
get out of here and just kicked him out in the street and you have a bunch of
people walking around talking to themselves that used to be in hospitals being
cared for.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
You,
you raise all of these complex issues and I just hope that the public as a of
this show your show and other things that are going on,
I just hope that they ask these tough questions and that they are critical in
their own sort of views about these things because we can all learn as we go.
I think it all really comes down to people like you and if there wasn't guys
like you providing the data and doing the hard work and sticking your neck out
there and doing all these shows and doing bill O'Reilly and,
and you know,
disseminating the actual facts and the data and doing so so confidently and uh,
I think it's awesome man.
I really appreciate it.
I appreciate you coming on the Shank two man.
I am very,
very important.
So folks,
please support go,
go buy his book.
It's called high price.
You can get it at high price is high price the book high priced?
The book.com.
Um,
I'm sure he can get it on Amazon,
right?
Do you have a audible version of it as well?
Audible version.
Did you read it?
No,
they always do that man.
They fucking deceive Rinella.
My friend wrote a book and they did it to him to,
they had some fucking actor to read his book.
No,
I know.
That's wack.
It's your buck.
I'm going to make sure I tell my editor that next time.
Tell that editor shut your mouth.
I want to hear the guy who wrote the book,
read the book.
I want to hear the woman who wrote the book.
Read her book,
man.
I want someone else reading your book.
Full stupid,
right?
Know you got enough juice so this will happen next.
It's got to happen.
Whoever it is out there making those audio books.
Get your shit together.
Dr. Carl Hart doesn't need anybody reading this book.
Silly freaks.
All right,
I'm go buy the book and follow him on Twitter.
It's Dr. Carl Hart on Twitter.
There's h,
a r t on Twitter and a thank you man.
That was awesome.
Thank you man.
It's a pleasure meeting you.
My friend.
Good friend Chris Ryan told me I had to come hang out with you,
so thank you man.
Yeah,
I love Chris Ryan and we do a podcast once a month together.
We don't have a name for it yet,
but what we do is for folks who've listened to the ones with Dunkin and Chris,
Ryan and me,
we do my podcast next is Dunkin's,
next is Chris's and we just keep doing it.
So we do one a month together.
We haven't known name for it.
We need a new name,
but he speaks very highly of you as well.
I really appreciate you being on.
Thank was awesome,
Dr. Carl Hart,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Thank you to squarespace.com for uh,
for sponsoring our podcast.
Uh,
I should know that fucking URL buy now,
but of course I don't sponsor copy.
Um,
squarespace.com use the code word Joe that's a for 10% off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com and use the code word Joe Squarespace and all in one
platform and easy way for you to design your own website and do so in a,
in a really impressive fanning manner.
Uh,
thanks also to stamps.com.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone and enter in the code word j r e for our special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage that stamps.com and
use the code word j r e were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o n
I t,
makers of Alpha brain.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
we will be back tomorrow with Amber Lyon.
It's going to tell us a,
a fascinating tale of our,
her,
uh,
her entrance into the world of psychedelic trips.
And Matt,
the terrorist Sarah Former UFC welterweight champion will join us tomorrow at
3:00 PM as well.
So much love to everybody.
Thank you everybody who came out in Dallas.
We had a great time.
It was so cool.
And uh,
we'll see you soon.
Much love.